i
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
[Music]
what up and welcome to the mlb game of
the week pregame show presented by state
farm you see the bay area just stunting
on us right now the golden gate bridge
and now oracle park
the site of today's mlb game of the week
live on youtube
milwaukee brewers in san francisco
giants finishing up a four-game series
the crew getting loose
they've improved to 82-52 winners of
four in a row
they handed the giants a fourth straight
loss that ties a season high bill ripken
steven nelson here in studio 42 in
secaucus rip how we feeling we're
feeling good i love oracle park i would
say that's in my top five it's a nice
yard it's a nice great yard and it's a
great day for a ball game and a great
day to turn things around if you're a
fan of the san francisco giants it's
been a great season to be sure yeah but
they wake up for the first time in a
long time a long time and they're not in
first place anymore it's not really
because anything they've done wrong the
dodgers have just been that good behind
them well that's a problem that you're
facing when you're in the nl west right
now is you knew going into the season
the dodgers have a very talented roster
oh and by the way they went out there
and got mad max and trey turner at the
trade deadline
just to help them out but no i i looked
at this race simply as this if san
francisco doesn't win the division
it might not be because of uh shall we
say a collapse or they faltered yep the
dodgers are just good now they've still
got 30 games to play and they've got
time to get it done and today is going
to be a start of that because they're in
a four game skid yeah so you got to win
today to try to make up that ground
again against the dodgers the dodgers
are coming to town for a series this
weekend but right now they're dealing
with another buzz saw in the national
league that being the milwaukee brewers
let's show you the highlights from last
night
now lorenzo kane bases loaded pitch line
drive base hit right field one run
scores here comes narvaez towards the
plate the throw from bryant offline it's
two-nothing
milwaukee game seventh inning
and peterson into left field of base hit
the brewers will take the lead as kane
scores
kane rips one towards left
back at the warning track at the wall
it's off the top of the fence and did it
stay in play here's the call home run
lorenzo kane will circle him
[Applause]
all right rip what has the brewers
shown you in this series against the
giants i mean because we've been talking
about the staff all year and we're going
to visit with corbin burns a member of
that pitching staff in a little bit
but lo kane getting going
christian yelich getting going willie
thomas has been like an mvp for them
what are they showing you i think for
the most part though when you saw that
too the record 82-52 30 games over 500
i'm not so sure we thought that they
were going to be this good
when the year started but they have
shown me you talked about the bump
that's the first thing that jumps out
there at me is the starters are nasty
their bullpen might be nastier if if
that's possible but the boys getting
going offensively you're going to need
to etch a few runs out down the stretch
once the postseason starts i should say
because i think they have the situation
in hand where they can coach into the
postseason it'll be eric lauer today for
the milwaukee brewers on the other side
you have logan webb who's perhaps the
hottest pitcher on the planet right now
and you want to dive in a little bit and
that brings us to how to some people you
go online the old youtube.com how-to
well how to make a simple adjustment rip
how has webb done that well i think he's
just changed the grip on the fastball a
little bit and i want to show you that
two-seam fastball that i'm talking about
and we can explain that later look at
that thing dive down and into righty's
and if he has the ability to throw to
that side of the plate makes him very
very nasty the breaking ball also he's
become this two-seamer sanker slider guy
is what we used to call him back in the
day and that slider is real so when you
can carve up the plate you can aim to
the middle and one goes this way and one
goes this way it's all good i want to
look at this at bat here chapman
this is what a sanker slider guy can do
so look at the misery he's in
look at this ball hit him in his foot
right here and the pain that he's in
so now he's got to go back into the
batter's box going i don't want to go in
there and then he has this arsenal where
he throws the slider away because he
don't want to foul another ball off his
foot so that's a three-pitch uh ordeal
right there sank her in john gomes comes
up later in the game i'm gonna introduce
mr change up to you after hitting that
part of the plate and then he's gonna
follow the same track with a split
change at 86. so fastball change up
slide piece right here see you later it
got me thinking about this guy this guy
back in the day jake peavy
was there's the outside part of the
plate that two-seam comeback fastball
that he had he could also throw it in
there but the sanker slider that this
man had and the willing willingness to
go compete was pretty real that breaking
ball is filthy when we put them side by
side freeze this for me
and when i get this glove up fully into
the position i want you to freeze it
again so get that hand up in there keep
going
keep going freeze
both guys are almost identical in that
mode and i don't know what it
necessarily does to the hitter right
here but it's something about throwing
that glove up there first it's like
peekaboo and then it's gonna get out of
the way play it through we're gonna look
at these two seam fastballs on the
outside part of the plate that are
almost identical as they go and then
we'll do the breaking ball and freeze it
again on that same point out there when
that glove gets high
that's pretty good right there i mean
look at this it's almost identical what
you do both guys also pitch
from the first uh base side of the
rubber i thought was interesting because
what that does that tells me when the
guy's doing that
this side of the plate is his bread and
butter
and that two-seam fastball and that
breaking ball can come to light play it
forward please
but the ability to be able to do
fastball slider fastball slider fastball
slider it's almost like you're going
down middle of the plate one's going in
one's going away and when you look at
the pitch you should then we talk about
making simple adjustment look at the
four seam fastball that logan webb threw
in 2020 33 of the time down to 11. but
look at this anchor
15
up to 36 and also that slider usage is
up so i look at him even though that
changeup is a nice weapon and it was a
little split change that i saw on on
john gomez when we slowed it down and
really looked at it the sanker slider if
you can aim towards the middle one's
coming in and one's going away yeah this
dude at home played especially
right-handers
it's amazing and what i want to talk
about that four-seam festival the how-to
thing if we can get in here
four-seam fastball is simply that it's
across this big horseshoe that's a
four-seam fastball what that is designed
to do is basically spin this way and it
goes point a to point b if we change the
grip and both pv and logan webb are kind
of three-quarter guys that throw from
here when you're letting this thing go
these seams right here find a way to
fight against the wind and that's what
pushes the ball down so that's the
sanker right there so one simple
adjustment a four-seam fastball
sometimes from here has a tendency to
flatten out especially if it doesn't
have that extra giddy up at the end a
lot of guys that are four seamers are in
this position to get that rise to get
that lift and that works but that two
seamer sanker slider that's a great arm
slide both of those guys have it for the
uninitiated we've never stood in the box
there's a difference between a sinker
and a sanker
this anchor is that look that chapman
gave you
because back in the day okay i faced
guys like billy swift kevin brown scott
erickson and i knew what that was like
did that there's a couple of things when
that sanker's coming down and in on you
i love it there's three things that can
happen if you're the hitter one you can
hit it hard but it usually goes in the
duct there yeah so now it's one
two you keep it fair you hit it about
this high off your knuckles and you
break your bat or three
you call a tow truck yeah because that
ball is going down on the foot all three
stink yeah none of them are good no no
good that's a sanker so logan webb his
last 13 turns has been terrific two or
fewer runs allowed in all of those and
the giants have won 12 of 13. he's
basically become one day they need a win
today and that takes us to our mlb game
of the week poll presented by state farm
who will win today webb and the giants
or eric lauer and the milwaukee brewers
that is the pitching match up speaking
of pitchers why don't we talk to a
couple when we come back corbin burns
who faced off against webb on the 6th of
august we'll talk with him and amy g is
talking
as well
[Music]
there's a base hit
wong slaps one to left here comes kane
aquino's throw to the plate and kate is
in there
rbi single
cold wong
it is 4-2 cincinnati
[Applause]
[Music]
in the bottom of the eighth it is 7-4
now my goodness how big is that
boy he's come up with some huge hits
and big home runs
two out
two run home run
colton wong with three rbis in his last
two at-bats long now top of the order he
has struck out twice in this one and
this will line down the right field line
and it's gonna play to run for milwaukee
two runs come home
took a while for the brewers bass to get
going in this series but here they are
that was a change up first pitch
and colton able to wait back that pitch
was up down the middle and smokes it
down the right field line
[Music]
welcome back to the mlb game of the week
youtube pre-game show presented by state
farm we got a special guest with us rip
corbin burns of the milwaukee brewers
burnsie great to talk with you again
last time we visited together it was on
a youtube broadcast against the reds and
one of those reds we heard joey vado
talk about how this is the best staff
he's ever faced in his career so corbin
that's where i want to start when you
hear a hitter like joey votto say
something like that how did it hit you
uh i mean that's a great compliment um
joey's been in this league for a long
time and faced a lot of good hitters um
i think he even compared us to i think
it was the 2010 phillies yep some of the
guys that were on that team were pretty
unbelievable so to uh to kind of get
that
recognition from from joey a guy that's
been a league for a long time is pretty
special and um you know i know it's
something that myself along the other
guys in this in the staff take good
pride on uh corbin take me into your
little uh trip right now into into san
fran you throw monday throw well get a w
and then you wait you got just the rest
of the week off that you're in san
francisco hanging out and you watch your
boys go out there and play but take me
into your routine on the road shall we
say because you pitch on monday you know
what's your side day like and what's
going on there and do you just kind of
kick it on those extra off days
yeah so the last couple days it's kind
of been you know pretty relaxed um you
know my day after and two days after are
you know pretty laid back it's more
about you know getting the body
recovered and
you're trying to feel good after the
last one you know at this point in the
year i've i've you know don't really
throw a bullpen anymore it's more about
just recovery and
get what i need to get done and catch
play and some some flat ground in
between so
yeah it's been it's been a good couple
days the last two days i had a bunch of
family in town so i got to uh got to
spend some time with them entertain them
a little bit and
you know watch watch these guys um you
know win a couple games i was just gonna
say this is no ordinary road trip of
course you went to college at st mary's
right there in the bay area i imagine
you had a whole village there at oracle
park did you not
yeah yeah i had had some friends close
uh my wife's family is uh a lot of them
are from up in this area so
it's a pretty good homecoming to uh to
not only see them and and the friends
but uh you know just to be back in the
bay where where i played some you know
some of the years of call of baseball
you know nellie talked about that staff
and i assume joey votto usually hits on
the starters but last night's ball game
you got to watch a a plethora of
relievers just coming in one after
another doing the job what's that like
on a nightly basis maybe when you do
turn the ball over you go back into the
dugout knowing that the game's in pretty
good hands
yeah i mean our bullpen has been
unbelievable um you know when when we
know we only have to go six innings to
hand the ball over to you know to box
burger williams hater combo at the end
of the game it's you know it's pretty
special um
you know even even you know when you
starter gets roughed a little bit
earlier we got a you know go to cousins
or strickland or suitor early on um i
mean those guys have been unbelievable
all year they've you know they're
a group that needs to be credited for
you know for a lot of the a lot of the
wins we've gotten you know being in
first place so far this year so your
staff top to bottom starters to the pen
has gotten a lot of ink a lot of run
this year and rightfully so joey vano
and every all of us tv clowns etc etc
who is the guy on your staff
that makes you step back and go wow he's
he's gross who's the filthiest guy on
your squad oh
jeez
i'd have to go you know between williams
or hater at the back end um
you know
i think most hitters know that devin's
going to throw a change up and they
still don't hit his changeup
um and then i think pretty much the same
goes for hater you know you're going to
get a fastball at the top of the zone
and guys know it's coming and still
can't hit it so
you know the numbers they put up the
strikeout numbers they put up um it's
it's pretty special and you know as a as
a starting staff it's nice to have you
know those two guys to to lock it down
at the back of the games you know you
talk about their strikeouts um you're
not too shabby at it yourself um but the
thing that gets me probably as much as
this is the punches is the no walks that
go with it so take me through your
mindset like when you do give a free
pass is that one of the things that's
just so taboo you just don't want to be
dealing with
yeah so i mean early on in my career
that's something i struggled with is you
know i felt i got in trouble by putting
guys on base giving guys free passes so
that's something um at the beginning of
last year was really my focus like you
know i i know i can attack the zone i
got good stuff um just i just don't want
to hurt myself i don't want to put guys
on base i want to make them earn it so
um yeah you know if i i i could say i
get a little upset when i walk a guy um
you know there's some situations where
you know walks not the not the worst
thing and i have to tell myself out
there like hey it's okay there's a base
open you're fine so
uh but yeah you know for me that i like
to take pride in limiting those free bas
free paces and uh you know making those
guys earn it last one carbon before we
let you go this is the movie game of the
week live on youtube favorite youtube
video of all time
oh geez favorite youtube video um i
think the one i still crack up is is the
the charlie bit me where uh
the little brother bites the older
brother's finger that's that's the first
one that comes to mind that one's that
will make you laugh every time yeah and
we're so old now i think they just
graduated college corbin burns one of
the studs on the milwaukee brewers staff
thanks so much for taking some time out
matt stay healthy keep shoving and we'll
see you in the post
awesome thank you guys i had charlie bet
me in my head now there's the pregame
sites from oracle park so rip and i are
here in new jersey well scott bronshon
ss tim dillard are on site in san
francisco as is amy g who visited with
logan webb today's starter visited
yesterday here's their chat
all right logan webb with us and you
have clearly emerged as one of the best
giant starters this season and it's been
a fun storyline to watch you through
your career what do you feel has been
the turning point for you logan and
finding that coveted consistency that
starters seek
you know i think you know i think cap
has has talked about it a lot
i think the main thing is just attacking
attacking the zone and
uh you know i i thought we were we were
doing really good that at that in spring
and then
um you know the first month month and a
half uh i had some good starts had some
bad starts and
i feel like right before i got hurt i
was starting to
kind of figure it out he could find it a
little bit and unfortunately i was hurt
i had to stay out for a little bit but
then just kind of staying with that same
mentality and
of attacking the zone
going into the rehab starts and
everything and didn't know whether or
not i was going to be
coming out of the bullpen or starting
and
you know luckily i was i was i was able
to keep starting and um i think i just
once you get in a groove you jus you
you just feel good out there and
you just get more confidence each time
for sure so confidence attacking the
zone is going to be key against this
brewers lineup they are deep but you did
face them in early august so you have
that experience plus the benefit of
being able to watch them for three games
here at oracle park to see what they do
how dangerous is this lineup and and can
you share the key to being able to
contain them without giving away your
game plan
um yeah
they got an unbelievable team um
honestly it's it's it's the mentality is
the same just kind of you just got to
attack them i think they
they're
i feel like all good teams are kind of
like this where
if you get in bad counts
it's
when you have good teams that have good
hitters they kind of they'll get you on
that
and i think this team is no different uh
they got a lot of
you know power hitters they got guys who
get on base they got guys who who get
walks they
they got a really good team and um you
know especially with with their pitching
staff to with that as well
so i'm excited to face them it was fun
last time
it'll be it'll be a you know a good good
game again i think it's going to be one
to watch for sure last thing i want to
ask you about is the slogan this year
one of many always with the giants is
let the old guys play and a couple of
those old guys were winning some
championships when you were in high
school crawford posey
belt what has it been like to experience
being their teammate
what have they given you in their
veteran leadership to help you with your
career
i think the best thing about those guys
is just how they come to the field every
day and they just work
they know exactly what they want to do
each and every day
and just finding that like consistency
and that routine i feel like if you
that's that's what i try to learn from
them the most especially you know guys
like buster's who who i get to throw to
every time and
um
just kind of picking his brain about
everything you know
i always ask i feel like i've asked him
like 10 different times like whose
favorite pitcher was they caught
he's probably told yeah like i said 10
different times but just like finding
out little things that he likes and um
just all the guys have been have been
awesome and
they're the main reason i think why
we're in the position that we are right
now because of what they've done before
and
they just know how to
be
professionals and
i've learned a lot from being able to
watch them it certainly rubbed off on
you that's for sure we see it logan went
thanks so much for your time
all right let's turn it up the creator
spotlight is shining on dawson right go
ahead and subscribe to his channel close
to 50k subscribers he's also a massive
san francisco giants fan so it's
appropriate that we have them on as
we're about to watch the only game of
the week live on youtube featuring the
san francisco giants dawson joins us
from pennsylvania dawson great to
digitally meet you of course everybody
can go to your channel and they can
get anything from video essays on what's
going on right now current events and
major league baseball rankings to also
learning about baseball history so i
love that it's for fans of all ages and
of all levels of interest
being that you are a fan of the giants
you wake up today yeah your team is no
longer in first place first time in a
few months how you feeling be honest
with me you all right uh
yeah you know it's it's tough getting
used to but honestly if you were gonna
tell me at the start of the season that
we were only going to be half a game
back i would be absolutely thrilled so
yeah it's tough getting used to but i'm
still confident with where the team is
right now see all you fans watching that
is how you fan right perspective okay
but what do you want to see what has to
go right for the giants to kind of win
this battle with the dodgers la's coming
to town that's a big series and they
could take first place right back but
what do you want to see out of your club
uh well the offense really needs to show
up you know posey's been struggling
lately
i am really concerned about the starter
depth with wood and cueto going down so
until they get back they're gonna really
need to rely on this bullpen to help
carry them through the games with some
help from the offense as well now
phantom aside you can objectively say
that this national league west race is
incredible because it's not just san
francisco and la yeah the padres one of
the most electric electric teams
in the league now granted they hit a
summer swoon and are now battling for a
wild card spot they were your number one
ranked preseason team correct do you
believe they can hang on to a postseason
spot
yeah well i thought out of all the teams
they truly had the best offseason and
were set to be a division contender
world series contender um you know their
schedule for the rest of the year it's
not going to be nice to them they don't
have the type of easy schedule the reds
do
but with you know tatis coming back they
hit that summer skid i really think
they're better than that
i think they're a more complete team
than the reds are and i would say i have
them taking that second wild card spot
yeah nobody could have predicted kind of
just the the unhealth unhealthy
injury bug that is bitten the pitching
staff time and again fernando tati's
junior few aisle stints as well but okay
big picture now not just the division
that you were paying most attention to
all of baseball what september story
line really has you locked in
you know i'm i'm really interested in
following the seattle mariners um
they're having a lot better season than
i thought they would believe right now
they're three and a half games back of
the wild card spot and you know then
making the playoffs a big deal to that
franchise they've been rebuilding for a
while now they've got some good pieces
uh but i really think they have a shot
at taking that second wild card spot and
making the playoffs would be huge for
that franchise this year all right
dawson i think you have a lot of
subscribers right close to 50 000. the
og ones they know the chapman challenge
though
so
taking this back to the chapman
challenge and for those who haven't seen
it they're one gonna go watch in a few
moments but just break down what
happened here
okay so the chapman challenge basically
what you want to try and do is simulate
catching chapman so you get a shorter
distance away from your catcher and you
just
you just want to see you know
how fast he's able to catch from that
distance that last play for my poor
catcher jayden just took one right to
the chest um that was about 140 miles an
hour simulation i i believe he was able
to catch 110 but um yeah that was a
challenge a few years ago i hope people
start to bring it back because it it was
a lot of fun it is a little dangerous
don't try it at home but um yeah it's
it's something great and it's something
that really helped kids start my channel
too yeah it's awesome man would you
rather catch chapman in real life or
have somebody do that challenge with you
now
uh i'd say somebody do that challenge
with me now because um you know chapman
you still get a little bit of movement
on there you know right with that with
that tail you're done behind the plate
you're done yeah uh dawson wright
again subscribed to his channel it's
great to visit with you man hopefully we
could do it again soon i know your
favorite memory was the 14 giants that
was a different decade maybe instead of
even your magic it's odd to your magic
we'll see but thanks again man
thank you for having me
thanks again to dawson right there is
eric lower he's really got it going
lately i mean you look at his last nine
turns he's got a 2-2-3 era he's got the
ball today for the crew on the road in
san francisco we come back we got some
picks to clip from rip
[Music]
basketball ella was hit well to right
center field mike kistrepski can watch
it it's gone
and by plenty a two-run homer his 20th
of the year three-nothing giants
451.
he hits one and nobody was there right
into center field a lead-off single
known to mikey stremski who got the hit
that started the rally and he lines this
one into center field base hit us
his second hit of the game
that lined it right back up the middle
base hit mike kastrepski into center
field for a lead off single
stremski drives that one out to left
center field
going back peterson all the way to the
wall and it's gone mike gastrebski
to left center field
that's a beautiful swing
four nothing giants
out of the left center field that one's
going to get down and that's going to be
another run peterson will cut it off
wilmer coming in
he scores into second standing
yostremski
five nothing giants
what an impressive rally this has been
[Music]
getting close to the end of the line on
the mlb game of the week pregame show
presented by state farm
all right now it's time for picks to
click presented by fanduel sportsbook
back with rip here's studio 42 i want to
know rip do you think chris bryant hits
a home run today i'm going to say yes
and i know that i usually go on the
underside of that because it's not that
easy to hit home oh look san fran they
need to uh stop the bleeding here they
need a w this man might be the one to go
bridge right here so i'm gonna say yes
now you broke down logan webb and the
adjustments he's made last year to this
year he's a ground ball pitcher like
second highest ground ball rate in the
majors but we're looking at punch outs
today six and a half as we're setting
the over under where you going oh that's
a tough one for me right there i think
that's gonna be under i'm gonna go with
six stay under that's a good mark though
the six and a half makes you think i'm
gonna say under but i'm still saying he
pitches extremely well but under six and
a
half
so he's got to face the milwaukee lineup
which does not have willy adams in it
today just getting a breather it is his
birthday so happy birthday willie
now the brewers are averaging 4.7 runs
per game in this series this far the
first three games they've won all three
over under three total runs for the crew
another good number right there
i tell you what logan webb has been so
good yeah two or fewer in the last 13.
i'm gonna go ahead and say under that
one because i'm putting a lot of the
eggs in that basket okay if you didn't
notice san fran winning yep means
logan's gonna pitch well because k.b is
going bridge too okay so again all the
eggs in that bag gets the sense that you
you're leaning towards a giant's victory
but the number of runs that's still a
question for you so i'm gonna set it at
four and a half well i'm not fandol
schwartzman is what are you gonna do
four and a half for the gigantes yes i'm
gonna say over
okay i think that look you just lost
four in a row it's their first four-game
skid
no reason to panic you're in a good spot
right there you're still in second place
just a half game back from the dodgers
go out there and play a good game
put some runs up on the board let logan
webb do his thing all right so we got
rip's take on not just those plays for
this game but also the result he's
leaning sf what about you
we put the question out there on the mlb
game of the week poll there you go who's
going to win wow 55
agreeing with you bill ripken you're a
man of the people you always have yeah i
don't know about that i'm just saying
that 55 percent of people out there got
a pretty good idea what's going on look
logan webb has been really good yes he
has like i said this is the first four
games kid by the gigantes i don't think
they're gonna go to a five-game schedule
okay last question i'm opposed to you
you don't have much time
right now who's your horse in the
national league cause these are two
front-runners who's the horse yeah
i still think it's the dodgers right now
when you look at them there's no reason
to think
that this season has gone the way it has
look they're they're good yeah the
dodgers are good and they're going to
san francisco next but right now it's
the brewers and giants scott braun
shawnesses tim dillard and amy gutierrez
are on the call it's the end will be
game of the week live on youtube enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
are you kidding me
[Applause]
game day in san francisco and this one
feels like it means more than most
regular season tilts you have the
hometown team stuck in the mud but a
sizzling arm for them on the mound to
try and save the day against a
juggernaut from the midwest this is the
mlb game of the week live on youtube
presented by state farm we have two of
the nl's finest for you today the
milwaukee brewers matching up with the
san francisco giants for some thursday
baseball to complete a four game set at
oracle park in california we are here
right now with you scott braun saying
hello to the youtube audience around the
globe and i'm along with former uh giant
sean estes former brewer tim dillard
also youtube star did you know that yeah
a little bit yeah i've looked up on
youtube how to be a good broadcaster so
so far
you're up to a great still early still
earlier both of these teams have been
off to not just great starts but they
carry that into the all-star break and
beyond as you can see the postseason
picture
features a brewers team that is 30 games
over 500 10 and a half up in the central
the giant skid has bumped them out of
first place for the first time since may
31st but still this team's in second
place they've exceeded expectations and
i've heard you took a trolley to get
over here is that true i absolutely took
control to get over here yes because
that's what most the giants have done
this year they've taken trolleys gets
the ballpark how have they done it you
can check out the painted ladies in the
background opening scene to full house
one of your favorites well they're the
first team in the major leagues to 50 60
and 80 wins there hasn't been a month
that's gone by where they have finished
less than five over 500 that's how solid
and consistent they've been they had the
best wreck of the national league for
107 days up until yesterday now they're
looking up to the dodgers they have have
they done it a team effort franchise 22
pitchers have wins two of the best on
the in the rotation and kevin gossman
logan webb see logan webb today second
best team era in major league baseball
and then look at that the franchise
record their home runs from september
1st how they've done that well 10
different guys have had 10 plus home
runs that lead to major leagues and
that's never been done in giants history
so what they do at the tread deadline
well they wanted to get more power i
guess well they went out and they got
former mvp and chris bryant who's fit
right in as a giant he's very versatile
he obviously can hit the home run he's a
great clubhouse guy so he's been a great
pickup for the giants uh and since
they've had him they've been even better
that was really nice of buster posey to
just kind of move over on the trolley
and make a little space for kb but hey
the offense hasn't shown up so far in
this series now we can give a ton of
credit to the brewers pitching staff as
they actually have not had a deficit the
brewers in these first three games
these are the giant struggles documented
at the moment but let's also make sure
that we highlight sean the fact that
this is an historically excellent start
and now really continuation into the
season as we're in september and look at
them 84 and 49 on the year yeah nobody
would have expected this coming into the
season they built themselves a little
bit of cushion it's inevitable they're a
playoff team it's just a matter are they
going to play a five gamer out of the
gate or are they going to play a one
game play off it looks like the brewers
are headed toward the five game playoffs
so
two great teams very evenly matched team
giants aren't playing their best
baseball right now but they got a chance
to right to ship with logan webb on the
bump today yeah that's one of their best
on the man we'll talk about him in just
a few tough act to follow i know you
don't get to hop on the trolley but you
do get to look up bartending 101 and
craig council is actually teaching the
course apparently yeah we're in
lederhosen too which we saw him in the
dugout earlier he was not wearing that
uh but here it is yeah here's brandon
woodruff man the big blue brew 18
quality starts this year you got corbin
burns strikeout man 189 strikeouts on
the year here comes another all-star
light said fred light on hits heavy on
strikeouts he got his first all-star
selection 20-21 there'll be more of
those and of course the airbender ale
devin williams following up his rookie
of the year last year with just an
amazing change up continuing doing what
he did last year and of course josh
hader coming in to seal the deal uh you
look at these guys and they're just
lights out they're mostly homegrown guys
and they're some of milwaukee's best
the pitching is sobering trump swings i
mean just keep adding on the lines for
what they're putting together on pace
for 99 wins brewers fans are like yeah
actually we'd like to clean 100 but
we'll settle for 99 if that's how it
works out tbra top three in baseball
they're really good on the road 46 up
and 23 down away from miller park
we're about to bring in the fourth
member of our team amy g will cover the
og trio for the giant she's gonna chat
with brandon crawford before we get to
game time in san francisco
see burns can deliver one here there's
burns a base head into left field
peterson winds it up he's gonna head
home no throw comes in and corbin burns
with his fourth rbi of the season
two two and he got him a buzz bomb on
the outside corner hater ready to fire
and a swing at a
fly ball shadow right center it is
garcia who makes the catch to end the
ball game
two-nothing brewers swing a high fly
deep into left field back dickerson way
back it is gone
halfway up the bleachers in left field
for lorenzo kane he hits that one into
left center field got some carry
yastrimsky on the run it's off the wall
takes a big bounce
tellez on his way to third it'll be an
rbi triple the brewer is three ounces
away from checking the first two games
of this four game series flores drives
one deep down the left field line this
one on its way it is gone
giant get a run on the board here in the
bottom of the ninth inning
so now the giants are down to their
final out
and the brewers have won back-to-back
games
we've got a beautiful day in san
francisco it's a great day for some
baseball we're gonna see the final game
of this four game series between the san
francisco giants and the milwaukee
brewers welcome back to our broadcast
everybody i'm amy gutierrez the giants
trying to salvage a game in this series
as they have dropped the first three but
that is not to say they haven't had a
very successful season in fact the
giants have been probably the biggest
surprise in baseball coming into 2021 no
one was thinking the giants was going to
we're going to be a contender but
they've quietly put together a very good
season we have heroics from players that
most fans are just getting to know but
there's three guys the giants fans will
never forget there are usual suspects
it's brandon bell that's brandon
crawford and it's buster posey not only
have they led this team with their
veteran experience they're each having a
career season they're contributing that
to this club brandon felt a career high
in home runs crawford a career best ops
posey as well the best since his 2012
season so surprise is kind of the theme
here because a lot of fans thinking it's
a surprise that brandon crawford's
having such a resurgent season season
it's 10 years for him in major league
baseball but i think a better word for
it is rewarded i had a chance to catch
up with the three-time all-star of the
gold glover about the amount of work he
put into his off season to have success
in 2021.
yeah i mean i think it started um when
this new hidden group came in and
i was basically open arms because after
2019 i you know not having a very good
year offensively i was i was open to
whatever these these new eyes had for me
um and so there was a lot of work put in
um like january and leading up into
spring training of last year of 2020
and i think
the results were were starting to show a
little bit last year obviously a
shortened season but so it would have
been interesting to see
what a full season would look like and i
think this is
you know kind of the results of
of that work that i put on in the cage
and then you mentioned workouts um i
think this off season i i just was a
little bit more consistent i guess
just because we didn't go on any family
trips or anything like that really and
stayed pretty local so i was able to
kind of stay on top of it more but also
just a little bit more like dynamic
workouts explosiveness and stuff like
that um helped out also
you pretty much only knew one manager
for the majority of your career in bruce
bochy now you've got kepler what has he
done to earn your trust and what would
you pinpoint it is about him that brings
out the best in you on the field
um
i think just
how he's able to kind of adapt and and
change just within the last year um that
i've been with him coming into last year
um
you know we didn't know exactly what to
expect it was a weird year and um you
know initially i think it was pretty
well known initially i wasn't gonna play
against lefties and um i think just the
the openness to to be able to see um
you know that that
yeah what guys can do or um
just being able to use his eyes and see
you know maybe experience or defense or
um you know lefties can help lefties
like stuff like that he's just he's very
open to that and um
you know this year has been has been
totally different he's you know he's
he's allowed starting pitchers to go
later into games even if you know the
numbers sometimes don't say to or um you
know lefties can hit lefties and stuff
like that well thank you so much for
your time the cherry on the top as we
wrap up with brandon crawford is he gets
to be a giant for two more seasons thank
you for your time brandon crawford
yeah i mean that's probably the biggest
reward right he gets to remain a san
francisco giant the team he grew up
loving until 2023. all right we have
lineups we have first pitch coming up
it's logan webb squaring off against
eric lauer don't go anywhere anyone
we've got day game baseball giants and
brewers coming up
[Music]
now lorenzo kane bases loaded pitch
lined right base hit right field one run
scores here comes narvaez towards the
plate the throw from bryant offline it's
two-nothing milwaukee on a two-run
single by lorenzo kane
takes into third
now brian
right center field
into the gap
that will go through
dickerson has scored and brian will stop
at second with an rbi double
so now buster he's due
right along the first base line of fair
ball
bring it around third he scores the
tying run and belt goes to third and
it's two to two
two on two out and a two ball two strike
count tie game seventh inning
and peterson in the left field of base
hit
the brewers will take the lead as kane
scores
and jace peterson continues to impress
lorenzo kane here's the pitch to him
kane rips one towards left
back at the warning track at the wall
it's off the top of the fence and did it
stay in play it did
and the brewers are going to take
another look at this one here's the call
home run
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the brewers and the san francisco
giants this has the feel of a playoff
type series there is a lot of buzz going
on with these two teams right now this
is gonna be a lot of fun hit a mile to
right get
[Applause]
he just put the crew on top
can you believe it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and he makes a catch
and this is gonna win it for the brew
crew
and the ball game is over
[Applause]
two of the top three teams in the
national league squaring off this
afternoon and finishing up a four-game
series it's the giants hosting the
milwaukee brewers it's all happening
right here live on youtube and youtube
game days are special mice up players
dugout interviews global audience you
can subscribe to the youtube channel if
you haven't already also brand new
feature in the last few weeks we rolled
it out
you can personalize your listening
experience
by listening to the home or radio calls
or us or just dj it go back and forth
you do you
pitching match up eric lauer
against the great logan webb wow he has
been fantastic especially in the last 12
13 starts and flower just now making his
fourth star coming off the covet i l but
on the season two mid-three's era
webb has allowed two runs or fewer in
each of his last 13 starts for as good
as kevin gossman has been this season
for san francisco webb has been the man
lately sean and let's run through your
state farm scouting report well logan
webb you want to clear the mechanism you
want to remove distractions you want to
focus on the pitch throw the catcher
without worrying about the hitter you
want to commit to every pitch sometimes
he thinks a little bit too much he's at
his best when he goes out there pounds
the strike zone doesn't think just
relies on stuff you want to continue
killing worms keep the ball on the
ground he's got the highest ground ball
percentage in the national league this
season at 61
and then two or fewer i mean 13 straight
starts he's given up two runs or fewer
which is best in the big leagues this
year and in those 13 starts his team is
12-1 the one run the one loss
coincidentally came against the brewers
in his last start against milwaukee
that's right that was on the 6th of
august he matched up against corbin
burns in that one but
webb was fantastic six innings one run
three hits nine strikeouts to just one
walk and went 91 pitches in that one so
second time around against the brewers
were underway on youtube and webb fires
a strike
at colton wong
brown sean estes tim dillard and ggg
[Applause]
garcia is having a career year peterson
is an on-base machine vogelbach is back
as of yesterday bradley a down season on
offense luke maylie was just called up
yesterday as well and he'll be catching
for eric lauer and here's luis urias who
craig council told us tim has really
relaxed himself since williams actually
took his job it actually helped him well
they put him in at everyday shortstop he
probably just went ready to kind of take
over that role that's a pretty big role
for a guy to do that at such a young age
but
willie dominus comes in takes that
pressure off of rhys and i mean
everywhere he plays he's fantastic
and he's been getting the job done at
the plate as well
i think sometimes we forget the ages
for some of these players just because
juan soto comes up or wander franco at
20 21 years old and looks like they
belong right away that's not the case
for everyone
marias has been
one of the better offensive performers
on the team this year that's a hot shot
to belt he found it the toss to webb
covering for the out with plenty of time
now great job by logan webb getting over
to cover first base you're taught from
the first day of spring training
ball hit to the right side your first
step has to be toward first base and you
can't assume the play is always going to
be made either so brandon belt nice job
of their positioning perfect right there
on that ball
hot shot off the bat at ureas another
ground ball for logan webb i mentioned
the ground balls that's two now to start
this game
61.2 percent ground balls this year for
logan webb that's best in the national
league and that's much better than his
mark from a year ago
former mvp christian yelich has hit
safely in 19 of his last 20.
well the reason why it's been an
improvement from last season is because
of his two-seam usage he's throwing a
lot more sinkers this year 36 percent
compared to 15 last year he's trusting
that pitch and he's getting great
results
gotten to miss and we're
gonna try and guess the run total for
milwaukee today odds courtesy of fanduel
it's just that three the over under both
of you take a shot at this and keep in
mind who's on the mound
and just law of averages i mean the
brewers have won the first three in this
series
yelich going to left side and brandon
crawford makes a sweet play fading away
real quick before i go to break over
under three runs for milwaukee today
under
the pressure's on crawford handled the
pressure very nicely the only man on the
left side of the infield he makes the
play three ground balls that's what
logan webb does and we'll see the giants
back next
[Music]
on july 7 2008 the milwaukee brewers
made one of the biggest trades in
franchise history when they acquired
reigning cy young winner cc sabathia
from cleveland they made the move with
one goal in mind make the postseason for
the first time since 1982.
we felt before we got cece that we were
a pretty good club but what cece did was
just give us incredible depth in you
know the ace departures
[Applause]
when we got cece sabathia we made it
loud and clear hey we're going to do
everything that we can do to uh bring
our fans post-season baseball sabathia
goes all the way what a masterpiece
sabathia went 11-2 with milwaukee
pitching on three days rest in three
consecutive starts down the stretch the
brewers win again and cc sabathia his
third straight complete game and on that
final day of the 2008 season cece
delivered his most clutch performance of
the year leading the brewers to their
first postseason in nearly two and a
half decades
[Applause]
what a pickup
three ground ball outs for logan webb
and the giants they produce that in the
top of the inning now we'll see if the
offense can produce and here's their
starting nine presented by state farm
austin slater will lead the way and then
chris bryant the former mvp in the trade
deadline acquisition brandon belt is
having some season he's had a
career-high 20 home runs darren ruff has
been a stud for them at the plate tyro
estrada is playing second today crawford
at short casalli instead of posey is
catching mauricio dubon was just called
up we'll go over that in a moment and
logan webb will round out the starting
nine we begin with austin slater
last night over three with a walk in
this time first pitch going after it
deep center field and forget about it
austin slater muscles up and the giants
are on the board with one pitch it's
their first lead of this series make it
one nothing on his tenth of the season
and that's why austin slater is on this
roster why he was with the club from the
get-go is to kill left-handed pitching
hasn't gone as well this year he was not
waiting around took a first pitch
fastball knows lauer is going to throw a
lot of fastballs with sitting on it but
the execution up in the zone he drilled
it to the big part of the ballpark and
the giants are on the board early trying
to set this tone looked like he was
probably in the dugout earlier going you
know what i'm going to swing first pitch
no matter what that has to be a free
that has to be predetermined as a hitter
doesn't it i think so i feel i would do
that especially as the lead off hitter
too
yeah there's certain guys as we watch
the pitch in the swing by slater just he
has a ton of power
he's hit some of the longest home runs
on this giant team this year but he just
hasn't been connecting
very consistently well he gets to hop
aboard the trolley now if you're
watching us at the beginning
10 players with double digit homers now
make it 11. yeah he was one of those
guys he was sitting on nine for a while
now 11 double digit home run guys it's
amazing that's crazy he was jealous he
saw the opening so i really get on the
trolley and fell a little left out it's
easy to watch us he was hanging out on
his phone inside the clubhouse but
seriously this team knows how to spread
the wealth and they have been on a power
surge all season long it's incredible
bryant lifts one gets under it
and jackie bradley jr doesn't have to
move much there's out number one
okay so eric lower was rudely
interrupted by austin slater on the
first pitch but the state farm scouting
report shows us a guy who's having a
great season tim yeah he loves day games
too make my day punk two
seven six era and seven day games uh i
mean not really conducive to what we saw
on the first pitch right there but it is
conducive to the accelerate early than
cruz he has trouble in the first couple
innings until he settles down and his
invisi cutter at the top of the zone
that's his bread and butter gets most of
his swings and misses on it
and it sounds good i have an invisi
cutter yeah what
was that first pitch in the visit cutter
or is that just a four-seamer i don't
know i didn't know
i wasn't changing channels i have
phillies and uh washington nationals
that we have in charge of the remote
juan soto was just up so i'm sure you're
locked in on that they put it down as a
four steamer so it wasn't the invisi
cutter he wasn't ready for it yeah
special occasions
well i'm sure we'll get a heavy dose of
the invisicutter today heavy dose of
movie drops as well from tim look out
sean
me and you are going to be tested
what was that first one from
tim which one you dropped one
with lauer oh yeah dirty hairy there we
go yeah
helen eastwood baby yeah
filmed here yeah
he lives down south in carmel
belt roller
long is as good as it gets at the
keystone two gone
you were talking about
logan webb and being a ground ballsman
lauer's not really the case it's kind of
the opposite he's a fly balls but he
doesn't mind giving up fly balls
i think that's an interesting thing but
if you're going to pitch at the top of
the zone that much you're going to have
to make sure you keep it in the park
as long as they're not barreled and hit
a long ways it's all right to be a fly
ball pitcher especially in this ballpark
this is you know matt kane pitched her
for a lot of years of being a fly ball
pitcher
the wind swirls in this ballpark it
tends to knock down a lot of home runs
they move the fences in
that's helped out a little bit
but this is still a really tough place
to hit home runs is which makes which
the giants have done this year even more
impressive
state farm defensive setup
three goal glovers out there for
milwaukee
ruff takes a strike i think lamont wade
junior showed us how
cozy this ballpark was yesterday he hit
a ball that turned into a double in the
late stages of a loss but it would have
been a home run in every other park
according to that cast
yeah if i had a dollar for every time i
heard that in this ballpark that would
have been a home run in every other
ballpark
yeah i mean especially triples alley i
mean that's just a really long ways out
there 4 15.
415 with a high wall
yeah lamont way junior against woodruff
the other night in his first about he
thought he got one squared one up look
he from his reaction looked like he hit
it out of the ballpark and then last
night again
same type of reaction and unfortunately
foreign
i guess he's getting his first taste of
oracle although he's been here
you know for a big portion of this year
we've seen a lot of those balls he hit
goes out of the ballpark he's been a
huge pickup for the giants
ruff pops one up that'll go out of play
ruff has been quite the pickup a couple
years ago he was crushing baseballs for
a few years in the korean baseball
organization
came back to the states and he's really
taken off with san francisco
if you're into ops plus and 100 is
league average he's at 149
that is comprehensive stat factors in
the ballpark and the league are in
he leads the team in that category
well he he's been i mean i know this is
going to shock some people but he's been
the right-handed version of max muncie
number wise this year with about 150
less at bats so there's something to be
said about that but when he's in the
lineup he's doing damage
payoff he walks
he'll do plenty of that as well
just like muncie that's right we'll take
a walk like you mentioned over a
thousand i guess left-handed pitching
against left-handed pitching of course
he loves lefties he's actually been
pretty good against freddy's this year
too but look at the obp for darren rupp
it was at 400 a few days ago he's just a
few ticks under that mark among the best
in the national league
i mean dylan i were talking about this
yesterday watching the game is that
that's that's what this lineup does top
to bottom they work counts they take
pitches they don't swing and miss a
whole lot not a lot of chase
tyro strata going after the first pitch
aligns it to left and christian yelich
is there hard hit baseball results in a
fly ball out but the giants pounce first
and take their first lead of this series
quash tag in the commentary section goes
wasting no time
that is correct
one zip san francisco threw one
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't stop smiling i'm so giddy to be
here and happy family's happy thank you
so much
it's a new chapter in our lives we're
closing one that was great and opening a
new one that's hopefully even better
coming to a team like this that has so
much history and winning ways and just
so many good veterans in the clubhouse i
was so excited that i was going to be
joining
i feel like there's no ego here i
mentioned the veterans and then you have
some young guys and people filling in
holes whenever they need it like that's
the type of team baseball that you want
and that's what i hope to do here too
coming from a team that hadn't won one
in 108 years having that on your
shoulders you know i hope would serve me
well in any type of playoff place or
pennant race here and hopefully all the
way to the world series you're the man
chris i appreciate it guys thank you so
much like i told kat when he first
called me i said i don't play wherever
you want me to i'm gonna hit wherever
you want me to
and i just want to win
one thing i really was excited just
wearing the orange and black you know i
told my wife i was like hopefully
hopefully i look good in those colors
we'll see his first game today
and fans he is here batting second
making his giants debut at third base
number 23
chris bryant
little sunshine out there now in san
francisco one of the best times of the
year to be at this ballpark and
really one of the best years to be a
giants fan yes i know they have quite a
few titles in their recent past but look
at the deal that they just pulled off
for chris bryant about a month and a
half ago and then it gets us thinking of
some of the other notable deadline
acquisitions like kevin mitchell future
mvp a couple years after they picked him
up jason schmidt javier lopez three
world series titles he was awesome for
them and then hunter pence of course who
is at the ballpark quite frequently yes
2010 2012 2014 they were in every other
year kind of thing and
it's 2021 i know it's an odd year but
it's working for him right now
there's kb so
let's start our first poll question of
the day best trade deadline acquisition
in giants history we give you the four
that we just talked about mitchell
schmidt lopez or pence
and
you guys are both new to the party here
so
i don't know if they told you but you
need to participate and give us your
answer and sometimes that even helps to
influence everyone that's watching on
their phone or on
their computer or wherever they're
watching tablet they might make their
choice based on what tim dillard says
well i actually know 100 pence name drop
so i'm going to go 100
logan webb picks up his first strikeout
after three ground balls in the first
shaun u
i'm going to say ding ding ding ding on
that hunter pence because i like world
series about you guys but you know
hobbies got a bunch of them and and i
love hobby and you know he's a
broadcaster so we're boys and
i'd like to pick him based on just him
being my buddy but uh hunter pence and
what he did
uh when he came over as a giant is not
just on the field but off the field
was huge in their run to winning the
world series in 12 and again in 14. just
the energy he brought every day
production on the field
you know was was solid but just what he
brought to the clubhouse
was uh was the difference
that's a strike to james peterson on
base jace they're calling him well
hunter pence you said ding ding ding i
thought you were gonna say yes yes
yes
i should have gone yes yes yes you
remember that that was that rallying cry
they had for
for that i don't know what year it was
but
for wrestling fans that's what daniel
bryan does yep
connor brought that into the dugout
it was working
it's all working for logan webb so far
this season he picks up another
strikeout
secondary pitches have been superb for
logan webb lately as we watch it again
and let's bring in amy g
[Music]
amy you got us
yes i have you gentlemen sorry about
that
uh-oh we'll get back to amy we don't
have her i know she was going to talk
about that nasty slider we just saw
logan webb
now daniel vogel back
and a little paint on the outside corner
that's the thing about logan webb this
year is that he's got the good sinker
that gets the ground balls but he also
has a plush change up and a swinging
miss slider
he's got three pitches he can get you
out with and if the location's been huge
because he's been making those pitches
look like strikes and then with two
strikes he makes him look like strikes
and then he end up being balls but his
aggressive getting ahead in accounts
with all those
and he gets himself yet another ground
ball played on a nice hop by tyro
estrada unfades so four ground balls
two strike gaps six up six down for
logan webb his team leads it one nothing
[Music]
it's brian wilson and it's all on him
the first out is the biggest out in any
closers inning josh hamilton steps up
he's got mvp locked up in my head and i
was uh fortunate to get you know
strikeout looking strike three call get
that call get that first out of the way
one down in the ninth then he gets
vladimir i think they ground out on the
first pitch so now we have two outs and
the giants after all those years of
waiting are one out away from winning
the world series and now i get nelson
cruz i got to two strikes
[Music]
looking at the dugout everyone's on edge
i can feel the electricity in the crowd
i'm gonna throw my best slider of the
year right now he hits a home run
whatever get the next guy and he swung
through they call it strike three
[Applause]
and that's it and the dream started for
the first time in 52 years
the giants are world champions
yes
[Music]
the san francisco giants are the 2010
world champions
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's the mlb game of the week live on
youtube presented by state farms scott
braun shawn estes tim dillard and amy g
joining us in just a moment from
gorgeous oracle park
here in san francisco california hello
to everyone watching us worldwide on
youtube this afternoon for just an epic
showdown between two of the best in the
national league brewers have taken the
first three in this four game set
and san francisco has actually fallen
out of first place for the first time in
a few months they're half game back of
the dodgers
entering the day now brandon crawford
who has the best batting average since
july 1. so the power has ticked down a
little bit sean for crawford lately but
he has been an on-base machine
i mean he's had an unbelievable year was
rewarded with a two-year deal
and on the hands a little squibber
and yelich will trot in for out number
one
was rewarded with a two-year deal and
coming into the season a lot of people
were thinking this may be his last year
he even mentioned that he was probably
not going to play against left-handed
pitching
he's proven everybody wrong he came in
with a chip on his shoulder believed
that he was one of the best shortstops
in the major leagues
and said don't forget about me i'm still
here and ends up making the all-star
team like i mentioned two-year deal
he's been unbelievable defensively and
you mentioned the average since july 1st
he's cooled off as of late as has a
couple of these giants hitters
offensively but he'll show up when it
counts the most good thing he stuck with
it two years 32 mil not bad
laura gets a whiff from kirk casalli
he showed that little stat on how the
giants have done when cassalli has
started
does it make a huge difference tim on
who your catcher is
it does at times you have to sit there
and trust the guy
uh if you're 100 behind a pitch and he
calls something different you shake off
and he calls the same thing again you
have to sit there and go one or two
places two places with it and you say
okay do i know this guy well enough
would i let him babysit my kids type
attitude and if you do you go with him
but you need that communication
because sally must be some babysitter
they love working with him he watches
one wide a ball and two strikes
logan webb has a one six nine era in
eight starts when kissali is behind the
dish
it's 3-1-8 in 12 starts with posey it's
no knock on buster it's just they really
enjoy working with kirk casalli who's
down on strikes it's the first punch out
of the day for eric lauer
yeah i felt bad for casalli yesterday he
gets in that bat off the bench and who's
he got a face in the ninth inning josh
hayder it's like here's a change up
here's the slider here's a fastball
that's a tough baby there's yeah
and he threw him change-ups on top of
that yeah hater did last night wasn't
even
had a nasty change up last night he did
and you mentioned it dilly that he's
worked a lot on that change up working
with devin williams on the change up
right i mean they're throwing partners
and and they play catch every day and
then you know you throw your flat ground
or you squat down in the grass and
you're catching and they just throw
nasty pitches to each other i've never
had that
yeah they work on and he's helped
williams is helping hate her out with
his change up but i'm like you're
throwing 99 from the left side why do
you need a changeup well we saw last
night he came in the game got a couple
stole a couple strikes with change-ups
it's nasty and then he can ride that
heater above the strike zone and it's
unfair
speaking of heaters above the zone
that's what lauer likes to throw as well
he's pumping them in there here in the
second
dubon goes after the o2 going the other
way trotting back is garcia
and the out is recorded
lauer will sit down the side in order in
the second austin slater touched him up
in the first that's why the giants lead
it one-nothing after two
you couldn't help but watch gorman
thomas rugged ferocious brew crew
personified
gorman was a guy that the town really
identified with and just fell in love
with
i think batting averages overrated to a
certain extent and the name of the game
is rbis and home runs from 1978 through
82 no player in the american league hit
more home runs
than gorman thomas and me being plugged
into the four hole there for a long time
was fabulous i base him girl there was
always somebody on base runners at the
corners and nobody out lined up the
middle for a basic
gorman thomas really comes alive when
he's got runners on base
and although he didn't look like your
prototypical center fielder gorman got
the job done
the least center field
looking outfielder that you'd ever
imagine
he was
big he wasn't fast he looked a little
bit out of shape
but what he lacked in style thomas made
up for with sheer hustle and
aggressiveness
gorman didn't leave anything on the
table he gave you everything that he had
that day
[Music]
hey those eduardo escobar should be back
in the mix for the brewers tomorrow they
trail one nothing and fans watching the
mlb game of the week live on youtube you
have your choice of listening experience
let's run through it gear icon there you
go
choose audio track select either primary
broadcast or you can select home call
away call whoever's doing this right now
is just doing an excellent job all audio
is seamlessly integrated on your
favorite devices so you don't miss a
minute of the action you can go back and
forth have fun with it and also we love
this on youtube paying off our first
poll question of the day best trade
deadline edition in giants history i'm
sure hunter pence is watching right now
and
he takes the title
tim and sean agreed 66 of the vote and
of course
2012 was a pretty good looking year for
the giants i'll take one comment from
one of our youtube creators as well as
jackie bradley jr fouls off the first
pitch from logan webb here in the third
made the cut said hands down hunter
pence because
in both the clubhouse and on the field
he was such a massive pickup just
echoing what you said a few minutes ago
sean
nasty slider yeah you guys got me in
trouble with hobby text me and said
you're dead to me
hey he's been a second hob i'm sorry
buddy we uh you know
i was just you know i was following
dilly there i i said whatever dilly pics
i i'm gonna go with you yeah you're up
here you're so nervous man you're making
me nervous
we have a few more of those to go so
pressure's on
there's the shift against bradley jr
that was no problem
for brandon crawford a couple innings
ago an excellent play
to retire yelich in the first bradley
strikes out it's been a tough season for
him at the plate and webb has k number
three on the afternoon
another slider
to strike it's not the pitch as much as
it is the location it's a strike out of
his hand and has such good late bite to
it down in the zone gets a lot of
swinging misses with that pitch and he's
been
talking about three strikeouts but he's
been doing this efficiently as well he's
made a quick work of these brewers
hitters so far
they would love a lengthy outing from
webb
the giants did have to implement a
bullpen game to start off this series
because johnny cueto was scratched with
an illness he pitched the next day and
then eventually ended up on the injured
list but
when cueto pitched that was in place of
alex wood who's on the covet il at the
moment so the giants are battling a bit
with their rotation at the moment
who's wasting no time yeah this is one
guy that isn't battling well he's
getting out on three pitches or less he
already has five in the game he's
throwing strikes with all his pitches
he's not going out there going here's my
fastball and establish this thing he's
been mixing it up change up slider
luke maley
comebacker for webb
there's two that's the thing about logan
webb is that if he has a pitch working
for him be it the sinker the slider the
changeup he'll ride that pitch
and he'll say okay he can he can locate
his slider as well and he'll say you're
going to have to beat me with this pitch
and until you do uh this is what you're
going to see a steady diet of and
his slider's been we talked about the
sinker being a big pitch for him but a
slider this year hitters are only
hitting a buck 61 off of the slider this
year with 60 strikeouts so that's that's
been a big pitch for him as well
you see eric lower does have one home
run this season
i'm trying to work up the pitch count if
i can there you go eric takes a strike
down the pipe i'll get this question in
there for you guys before we actually
talk to kevin gossman who's going to
join us in the next half inning youtube
creators you know what to do send us
your questions right now for gaussman
and we'll ask them in a few minutes but
made the cuts had better off speed
pitches
webb or gossman sean
i mean you watch him more so i go to you
first
that's a pretty good one
sean will answer later because logan
webb
is oh so economical this afternoon now
nine up nine down and his super teammate
kevin gossman is going to join us on
youtube in a moment
he
just smokes it
[Music]
[Applause]
that ball was crushed
strike three
that was a great play
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and something like this is what they
came for
[Applause]
catch your picture
you know chemistry let's do that because
it you don't automatically does anybody
want to be friends with me today all
right hey just cause i got a microphone
i mean we can't be friends get your hugs
a little baby
one two one two check check
this dude just keeps hitting the ball
and it's like not finding anything but
some lucky play
double smoke
agreed daniel vogel back miked up
players or excuse me right
sorry about that big boys at first base
but rowdy is miked up for us today and
he is going to provide a little
extra something for us
audio-wise all day
long
thank you rowdy
it's probably better he's not playing
you get more comments he gets we'll
probably get some good stuff today yeah
no one's going to stand around him
though
no but he still can go around other guys
right
he's still chase guys around the dugout
can you imagine if tim dillard was mic'd
up back in the day on the brewers you
would have walked up to each player and
almost done an interview show or
something no i'm way too scared playing
it would be a three-hour comedy yeah i
hated coming here there was so much
anxiety filled and now i'm like oh yeah
i get to enjoy a ball game it's fun
logan webb fouls the first pitch from
eric lauerback as we start the home
third and we are pleased to be joined
right now on youtube bye kevin gausman
kevin thanks so much for the time how
are you today yeah no problem thanks for
having me guys
so let's start with and we'll have some
questions from the youtubers in a moment
let's start with your thoughts on
yesterday of course wasn't the result
for the team in the end but how did you
feel about your performance yesterday
yeah i felt all right you know obviously
i'm
always trying to go deeper in the game
but you know trying to put something
together there offensively and it
actually ended up working out you know
alex dickerson came in pinch hit for me
and
hit a double and then uh you know chris
bryant came up and and put a really good
swing on the ball and hit a double and
scored a run and and we were able to tie
it up that inning so
um you know that's just uh national
league baseball for you sometimes
that's right and logan webb goes down on
strikes and actually speaking of which
let's get our first question in there
from a youtube creator for you kevin
dawson wright asks how impressive has it
been seeing the emergence of mr webb
this season
yeah it's been a lot of fun you know
logan webb is somebody that the last two
years i've been playing catch with and
um you know to just see the consistency
kind of come
day in and day out and just uh you know
his confidence level you can just kind
of see it on his face that
he shows up to the ballpark and he
expects to win you know he expects to
pitch well and
you know for a young pitcher i think
finally when you realize like
it doesn't matter who you're facing uh
you know if you can execute your pitches
you're gonna have success i think that's
a huge learning curve and
uh you know it takes guys a long time
but you know he's a guy his uh his pitch
has moved so much that um you know it's
just a matter of uh
you know being able to be around the
zone enough to the guys are gonna
respect it and so uh you know if he can
get ahead of guys he's uh he's he's
pretty nasty hey kevin shawn estes here
we got tim dillard as well um we were
gonna be asked a question by some i
think it was a youtube question earlier
fortunately we didn't get a chance to
answer it but i figured since we had you
on the broadcast now
the question was who has the nastier off
speed stuff you or logan webb
uh you know i would have to say webby
because he has two of them you know
he's got a nasty slider and a nasty
change up and
you know today he threw a change up at
90 miles an hour and it just went
straight down you know his ability to
make a ball move is
is really impressive and
it's a lot of fun to watch so i would
say him you know uh you know my split
can be really good but um you know his
movement on his even on his two seam is
is crazy at times you know watching him
throw bullpens i mean
he's a guy he can throw a slider that
moves
you know 20 inches horizontal and a
fastball that moves 20 inches horizontal
you know and so it's just uh it's fun to
watch him just kind of uh
move around the ball and you know he's a
guy
kind of like corey kluber that just uh
you know the amount of movement that he
gets is just impressive
there he is and austin slater's hooking
him up with a couple hits so far today
the only two hits we've seen this
afternoon come from austin slater a home
run on the first pitch you saw in the
bottom of the first and then
goes to the vacated right side for a
single with one out here in the bottom
of the third we're hanging out with
kevin gossman
hey kevin tim dillard listen man you
have a starting pitcher you have a split
finger a lot of times coaches aren't
even teaching a split finger anymore can
you give the give a little bit of
backstory with that because i know it's
a taxing on the arm thing and
how much do you throw it it's i just
want to hear the story behind it because
i tried it over several years it's such
a tough pitch to master and then how do
you stay healthy with doing it
yeah you know um health-wise i really
don't know why i think it's because uh i
threw i throw kind of a fosh you know i
don't throw like an actual true
split you know it's more fosh-like and
it's actually a lot like tim lincoln
used to throw and so
um you know i think that wear and tear
is maybe not as much uh
you know if it you know compared to if
you're throwing a true split um but yeah
you know with the pitch for me it took
me honestly five years to really feel
uh comfortable and confident with it and
for it to be consistent and uh for me i
was a guy that
uh you know i was typical a young guy
threw really hard had no clue where the
ball was going
i had a pretty good curveball you know
for a high school kid but could never
throw a change up was trying to throw a
circle change up and
i actually had my jv pitching coach um
chris baum
uh you know pitched in aaa for a couple
different teams and he was like
hey i threw this why don't you try this
and and really i just kind of stuck with
it and
i really didn't feel confident
in it until the summer before i went to
college really and in high school you
know growing up in colorado i didn't i
didn't really need a change up to be
honest you know it was uh
it just baseball wasn't very good there
to be honest and so uh you know i got
behind guys and there was throw heaters
you know it was i was a sinker baller
then and so a lot of ground balls but
you know it was a pitch that it's taken
a long time but yeah it's a lot of fun
and uh you know but it's definitely
frustrating at times you know it kind of
had a mind of its own at certain times
and uh
but when it's on man it's a lot of fun
we just saw your teammate brandon belt
fly out to center so now two on two outs
after the slater single we saw bryant
reach they're calling it an error
against
the third baseman jace peterson a couple
more minutes here with kevin gausman or
hopefully more for your sake
if the giants can add on here with
darren ruff digging in i'll hit you with
the hard stuff right now this is from
austin klechka hey kevin if you had to
choose would spend a day kayaking in
mccubby cove or head out to alcatraz and
get the full tour experience for your
kind of day i would say mccovey co for
sure you know that's something that
i always think is so cool you know it
doesn't matter what time the game is
uh whether it's at 12 45 or you know
seven o'clock at night like there's
somebody out there waiting on a home or
waiting on a splash ball and so i just
think it's really cool
you know i grew up a giants fan and so i
just think this place is really unique
and
you know i actually have a buddy in town
right now who was deciding if he was
going to do that today so i'm interested
to see if he's
maybe out there waiting for for one of
them and so uh you know it's definitely
something i think that would be really
cool to go out there one day
and hopefully and hopefully catch one
that'd be awesome
hey kevin shawn again um
i don't think people know this about you
but you're having a sneaky good
year at the plate believe it or not
i mean you haven't had a whole lot of at
bats in your career but you're hitting
almost 200 i'm how much i just want to
know how much pride do you take in your
hitting do you work on it a bunch i mean
you're not an out not to say that you
would have gone off the wall like
dickerson did when he pinched it for you
last night but i'm saying you're not an
out
yeah i mean you know i just try to uh
get in the cage every day and just kind
of see pitches you know i uh we have
this machine in there that
really kind of tommy listello brought to
spring training and they got these like
foam balls and
you know the movement on them is is
crazy and uh you know with with guys
stuff nowadays it's uh i feel like
getting in there every day and just
seeing you know nasty pitches seeing
rising fastballs sinkers and and cutters
and
you know whatever pitch a guy throws
they can they can put it together and
make it uh you know
make it resemble it and so uh going in
there and button off that i think
definitely helps you know and just helps
your confident up there but you know
it's definitely still a lot of luck
and uh you know sometimes eyes are
closed when you're swinging
you know you try to do something while
you're up there it's working for you
keep it up kevin thank you so much as
always for the time good luck for the
rest of the way one nothing giants after
three we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but just tell us baby how do you feel
about this young talent you have a lot
of dominican kids
he's got to go hit he's uh he's up next
he got to go he's got a hit he's on deck
this is before the inning and boba shed
all of a sudden someone did him
a bee sting or something just before
this half inning began and he's still
kind of looking yeah it's probably a big
surprise you stand out there and all of
a sudden something that bit him
[Applause]
stays alive
[Music]
you just never know with bottom as he
races jim wolfe but in the home run
jacket he can't fit it on
how long do you have to wear that thing
i think you should have to play defense
with it for a half an hour zamala is
going to try to make third and a good
read
wasn't graceful but it sure was
effective he's having an adventure
sometime he had no balance anymore like
a weeble it was crazy right
i mean does it get any better than that
that's our view
the mlb game of the week live on youtube
is presented by state farm it's the
first place milwaukee brewers in the
national league central matching up with
the second place san francisco giants in
the nl west
logan webb back to work top of the order
from milwaukee and it's colton wong
nine up nine down so far for mr webb
no fly ball outs yet for milwaukee no
lift from a team that does plenty of it
tough to lift a good sinker dilly had
one you'll tell me you tell them about
that sinker it's tough to get up in the
air yeah we're spot on right now you
with the ground balls me with the pop
flies
you know if you listen to these guys
you'll learn something i think
we had this conversation yesterday but
talk to bill about the sinker and and
the inability to to lift that with
launch angle like we've been like all
the hitters have been doing lately
and wong is down on strikes logan webb's
fifth punch out already this afternoon
amy g logan webb is looking good he is
and i get to add on to the love fest for
logan webb another giant so impressed
with logan buster posey i actually
hosted a q a with buster yesterday you
guys it was all kids and kids asked the
best questions and so the question was
who do you like catching the most and
buster said logan webb he's loved his
story you know he said he had a great
spring training then he dealt with an
injury and since he's come back he's
just simply been on fire and buster just
said it's so fun to watch a pitcher
start to believe in himself and then the
results that start to show up on the
field tim and shauni i don't know if you
guys remember that moment that you had
in your career where you felt like you
turned turned a corner and really
started to believe in your stuff yeah
still waiting for it yeah that's what i
was about to say that's why i'm up here
you know
i was waiting for one of those
tim he's got the lines yeah
that's all i got no it's it's very
important when you reach that moment and
kind of figure out what kind of player
you are and i can see that i was drafted
twice as the catcher when you see
somebody that has that light bulb go off
it is fun it should be fun to catch
these guys
it's like playing a video game in real
life
maria's into the corner and that is
going to punch off the wall
and turn into a stand-up double
a one-out double for urias
[Applause]
well that was an interesting
that bat right there he hits the ball
hard he's out over the plate 93 away
hits it the other way and i thought off
the bat it was gonna be foul he kind of
just looked at it the out slater just
looked at it and all of a sudden maybe
he thought he got it all i don't know
torch and right field
that hits off the bricks slater almost
makes a good play turns around he had a
chance at second base had he fielded it
cleanly i think he might have thought it
was going to be foul it kind of off the
bat it just looked like he couldn't pick
it up right away and then had to make up
for it with the legs but maybe it's
those wind gusts you were talking about
earlier
christian yelich takes one in tight well
this will be interesting to see because
logan webb had such a good rhythm
working out of the wind up now this is
his first shot in the stretch and he
already saw his worst pitch of the day
location wise to christian yellows let's
see if he can get it back at that
release point out of the stretch
down i always felt it was tougher with a
guy in second base the first time you're
out of the stretch then at first you're
so used to looking over the left
shoulder especially for a right-hander
but when the guy get a guy on second
base you're looking over the other
shoulder
you can mess with your uh mess with your
timing a little bit your release point
sometimes you can get a little bit be a
little bit too quick to home plate
that's what we're seeing right here in
the first two pitches to yellish it's
always interesting when you're in spring
training they harp on it big time and
you kind of lose focus during a baseball
season but pitchers have to work on that
as
ridiculous as you feel sometimes in a
bullpen where it's just you and the
catcher and the coach and you have to
look over your right shoulder at like a
wall that's behind you and you come set
because you have to work on the timing
you have to work on what's going on
around you you can't just be working
with the catcher and what you're trying
to do with your craft so
yeah if you don't practice it in the
bullpen the game speeds up on you
and
yes sports gaming universe in the
commentary section who said are we going
to be on alert for web today for that
thing that shall not be spoken about
yes that's the first hit of the day
before the brute crew
that thing is a no-no
he did it through three innings
and now a four-pitch free pass for
christian yelich to fill up for his base
yeah a couple things you look for in
pitch starting pitchers especially if
they get a nice rhythm early in the game
and they don't give up a hit the first
time is how they're going to do the
second time through the order or when
somebody gets on base
and we saw the first
example of that guy gets on base and he
loses his feel for the strike zone let's
see how quick it takes to him for him to
get it back unfortunately for him he's
going to have to face the middle part of
the lineup
he's going to have to navigate through
them
and you still have to make pitches
that's the thing that's what's tough
about pitching you can't make mistakes
you can't just say here hit it
you still have to continue to make your
pitches
i know it's only the fourth but with two
teams that know how to pitch this is one
of the marquee matchups right now
avasale garcia watches one sail inside
garcia
has a few at-bats in his career against
webb but one of them was a home run you
can see he's been delivering with
runners in scoring position he's been
one of their best all all-around players
and he's kicked it into another gear
since the month of july that home run
came when they faced off in milwaukee
and it was on a slider and it wasn't a
bad slider we actually looked at it over
and over again he was just looking for
it because his kryptonite for a while
was just swinging it sliders away and it
caught just enough plate for him to get
a good piece of hitting by garcia but
you go back to the first at-bat where he
struck out it was a fastball up so
pitchers remember they know they know
who's in the box
and it
wasn't too long ago about a month ago
webb faced garcia and the brewers
cutting a miss
the ball in two strikes
i look at it took him about five pitches
to get that release point out of the
stretch down and right there with a huge
pitch right there in a 1-1 count
i believe that was a change-up it could
have been his slide-ons a change up
there that was nasty bottom just fell
out of it and he's one of those guys too
that he'll throw his change up not just
the lefties typically you see a lot of
right-handers through the change up the
left he's slider to right now he'll
throw his change up to righties as well
that's just evil
right on randy righty on righty cambio
is just it's just wrong
i'll tell you what man it was the same
thing i was a lefty but i faced a lot
you know when i faced the lefty they
just didn't see a lot of lefty unlefty
change-ups so as i got later on my
career i started throwing that pitch and
i get a lot of you know look backs after
the swinging minutes like what are you
doing throwing me a change up that's not
that doesn't happen explain yourself sir
[Laughter]
[Music]
no call there angel hernandez calling
balls and strikes this afternoon
that missed in we've got the vantage
point
yeah you see cosali setting up a way he
wants him to finish it out front finish
that pitch down and away
got a little quick with the front side
that happens from time to time flattens
out even backs up a little bit on you
right as we saw right there with the
with the slider didn't quite catch the
inside corner
marias and yelich are on for garcia
2-2 on its way got him
six strikeouts already for logan webb
that was a big one and that might have
been his best sinker and he's throwing a
bunch of good ones so far this game that
might have been his best sinker of the
day that was 94 started down the middle
part of the plate went down and in
garcia swings over the top of it and had
he made contact with that pitch dilly it
probably wouldn't have been a six four
three or a five four three double play
straight up got him on the movement i
mean he can hit a fastball that's his mo
that's why you see him he sees a lot of
off-speed stuff but that worked because
that amazing change up he threw two
pitches before
slow him down speed him up that's that's
pitching 101 right there keeping that
rocking chair
on to jace peterson
jay struck out first time around
in game one of this series peterson was
three for three with a walk
clutch city last night as well two out
two strike rbi single made it 3-2 that
was the go-ahead run
just lofts one in the shallow center
it's going to drop and arias is on his
way home the throw is going to catch
yelichin between second and third but
the brewers do get a run
yelich still on the run
crawford is going to make the tag for
the out
to end the inning but the brewers get
their first run of the day
jace peterson a little bloop rbi knock
it scores urias one per side now as
logan webb is shaking his head and
saying a few things that might not be
safe for youtube
if you're one of the thousands who
follow willie adamus on instagram you
may be wondering what's with the hashtag
when you get to this level
sometimes you know things change you
know like you you get a new car you get
house a big house
and sometimes you know you get to your
head long ago adamus decided he wouldn't
let it get in his head as a 17 year old
in the dominican summer league he first
posted no book bag
that was in 2013.
it's a loosely translated spanish phrase
and adamus says it reminds him to stay
humble never boast and remember where he
came from which was a small town in the
dominican republic where he had loving
parents but not much else
that's what makes me appreciate this god
gave me this opportunity i got to give
it to others willia domes loves life and
lives it with humility and is surrounded
by family and friends who wouldn't have
it any other way
oh my god
they've
smacked me in my face probably
the brewers tied up at one in the top of
the fourth now we reached the bottom of
the inning and tim also by the way you
have permission to leave us for a little
and do whatever that guy was doing on
the bay that was
awesome i'm in
here's how we finished up the last half
inning christian yelich caught between
second and third but the run does come
across for milwaukee urea scores rbi
knock for chase peterson it's one apiece
and eric lauer is back on the mound here
to pitch in the home fourth against
estrada crawford and casalli
what was that
he was gliding on a
motorized surfboard i don't know
i wish i could say i saw it uh i might
have been able to help you out if i'd
seen it but yeah there's some crazy
things you'll see out of the bay you
know you see enough games
you're going to see a bunch of stuff
going on out there oh there he is
thank you that's the first that is first
i'm yeah
nothing surprises me in san francisco
but that that's a first i haven't seen
that one so nothing was pulling that guy
on that thing he's just by himself it's
got to be a motor underneath
yeah maybe the youtube creators in the
commentary section can hook us up with
an explanation there's someone google it
and help us out that was cool
you can say google right you told me
that oh for sure yeah see sean missed it
because he was too busy writing down
what that play was what was that play
well jace peterson single rbi eight five
four five six one more throw i run out
of room on my score card eight five four
five six that's my locker combination
yeah that's your zip code
estrada sends a fly ball to center
jackie bradley jr backs up a bit and
hauls it in
peterson coming up clutch again last
inning two out rbi the guy is just a
good ball player that was what was
interesting uh so we're
in the dugout with craig council before
the game because we're allowed to have a
you know a
three-on-one interview
with him and that's the only question i
asked i think except for why didn't you
ever bring me up in 2015 and 16 but
[Laughter]
no i asked him you didn't answer that
one but he did
push it aside but yeah he said that
peterson i asked him you know what's the
player that's most like you on this team
and the wright anderson he got the right
answer on that it was peterson he just
is such a good ball player he's so
prepared it was just it's just really
cool to see
a guy that i played with craig council
looking at this other guy going i this
is how i was and this is what we did and
that's what good teams need
yeah peterson plays all over the place
he's just a grinder you know that's what
you love about guys like that you wish
you had a whole club of them they're
just not all that aren't all built from
the same cloth and but you have to have
like you mentioned guys like that on
your team they show up every day they
want to play they want to be in the
lineup they'll play wherever you put
them put them wherever you want in the
lineup
and then they get it done crawford pulls
one into the shift wang puts him away
yeah and think about october baseball at
this point if you're a brewers fan you
know you're going to be there jace
peterson off the bench for a big a b
late in the game
yeah it could be a clutch knock but he
also spits at pitches and if you need
someone to get on base to kind of pass
the baton he is definitely going to help
fill the void there for a bench player
now we asked council what's his biggest
concerns and bench wasn't one of them
cassalli pops one up
here comes garcia for it
there we go again pitching has been
supreme so far today
after four innings lauer's giving up one
run so has webb we sail into the fifth
[Applause]
he's a very good baseball announcer and
if you listen to bob for five or six
minutes you want to say something that's
going to make you laugh
as driscoll makes the proper call
defensive indifference
or as we call it and score it
who cares
bob has had this wonderful ability to
give you the game and then bang you know
that's where major league three was
filmed
is that right yes i haven't seen it
don't
that thing was so bad it was on
airplanes the day we finished it
he's very funny on the air but he is
just an exceptionally good broadcaster
swinging a looping ladder base it to
right center one run is in they're gonna
try to score luke roy here's the throw
he's in there
[Applause]
you really feel the game through him and
while certainly he's
a brewer broadcaster so in that sense
he's a homer he's not a mindless homer
he'll give you a fair call of the game
morgan a smash up the middle base hit
the center here comes around third a
throw in the brewers win
all right well they say that champions
are won with pitching championships are
one with pitching and defense so who's
got some great pitching staff so we're
looking at one today with the brewers
and you know who's really into that joey
vado he actually said i'm just gonna say
it out loud personally i think this is
the best group of pitchers of course
he's talking about the brewers i faced
in my career i was a part of the team
that faced the 2010 phillies with the
late roy holiday cliff leroy oswalt and
cole hamels on the whole the entire
collection of brewers pitchers this has
been the toughest matchup i've ever come
across in my career so now we have a
poll question for everyone which teams
top three
are the scariest in a postseason series
you know what joey votto thinks i think
kepler might agree saying earlier today
that the brewers have one of the best if
not the best pitching staffs in baseball
gentlemen
thank you amy g i mean that's
a tough choice though even still when
you look at the competition for them
even in the national league
and you can vote and yes i'm going to
ask my friends here to help us out first
vogelback takes the pitch upstairs from
logan webb it's one in one i mean the
dodgers have a pretty nice looking
rotation as well bueller's a scion
candidate so is max scherzer kershaw's
going to come back at some point marias
is outstanding
white sox have something special
okay tim you first have fun which
starting staff top three is the scariest
yeah right i mean i think kind of i'm
kind of a blue brewer employee so i
think i have to go brewers but i've seen
them day in and day out um and they are
it's truly special you're going back to
uh zito hudson mulder of the a's back in
the day and and that's what it is you
have three guys that are having career
years that are all stars i mean do the
other teams all three others the
starters are talking about are they all
stars
i'm asking for a friend i don't know
yeah i i can help to answer that one i
know not for san francisco for the
dodgers scherzer yes
bueller i believe so yeah
i don't think arias was an all-star okay
so let's move to the next team white sox
i mean hey you want me to do the
homework we have research help too in a
moment there's we'll go back flying out
to center
one god
here we go
this helps thank you
for the white sox lynne rodon giolito i
think
geolito was not an all-star this year so
i think that yes i'm getting
confirmation as we go i'm talking
through it and tim dillard giving me a
pop quiz and the answer is the brewers
have the big three that are all
all-stars this year yeah pop quiz hot
shot yeah i didn't know they were going
to throw a graphic in there that's my
bad
[Laughter]
well i'll tell you what man i mean i'm a
giant employee and i don't i'm going to
still pick the brewers
i mean it's really tough to beat those
three now had trevor bauer been pitching
still or maybe even kershaw
i may go with the dodgers just
experience level you know postseason you
know the defending champs with
uh scherzer
bueller and either kershaw or bauer that
would be those those three would be
tough to beat but right now it's
nothing against eurius but
that three-headed monster of woodruff
burns and peralta is as good as it gets
and matter of fact
we got some notes on that in the last 40
seasons sub two and a half eras by three
teammates burns woodruff and peralta all
under two five the last time it happened
earl hirschheiser bobby welch and
fernando valenzuela the 85 dodgers
so that just goes to show you how good
they are and
being in san francisco for the last 11
years covering this team bumgarner kane
and lincecum were pretty good trio as
well
and they won some world series together
if i remember right yep
they did i think there's some signs on
the wall out there man
there's a few freddie peralta by the way
has been on the injured list with a
little shoulder issue but he is back
tomorrow for milwaukee perfect timing
bradley doesn't bite it's two and two
well you know we can talk all we want of
our opinion we're up here in this nice
little booth you know got a little cup
holder from a coffee so like
it's all about what the peers say so
you're going off joey vado chris bryant
the other day after facing corbin burns
was saying he got out of chicago so he
wouldn't have to face it anymore and
he's already faced him twice since he's
been with the giants
yeah kb's like can i not see them or at
least until the nlcs which certainly
could be a preview
that we're viewing
this week logan webb is absolutely on
fire
with the swing and miss that's a change
up there and bradley jr is thinking the
same thing do i have to face logan webb
again
in this game he's already punched out
seven
15 whiffs for webb
one shy of his career high of 16 and
we're only in the fifth and he's had 60
tosses
it's a big game for logan webb and a lot
of for a lot of reasons he's been
pitching so well
maybe the best pitcher in the last three
months this season in the big leagues
but the team's on a four-game losing
streak they haven't won since he took
the mound last
and to elevate yourself into a status
this is the type of game you got to go
out there and put your team on your back
you have to say okay boys that's enough
i'm gonna go out i'm gonna dominate
maylie clocks one to left field and he
finds some open space
he's gonna truck to second luke maley
sends a ball all the way into the left
field corner it's a two out double here
in the fifth and right on cue he gives
up a double but with that being said
there's two outs
those two out hits with the pitcher on
deck usually aren't going to hurt you
that often but yeah he just you know
this this is a big game he understands
that you know they need him today they
need him to go out there and keep his
team in the game
and he's doing just that so far
we're talking to gabe kepler before the
game
asking him about the future and he was
all worried about today he was like
we're only worried about winning today
and so he felt confident with the lineup
that he put out there the defense sure
he'd like some of those guys that are on
the injured list but i mean who wouldn't
every team wants their guys all healthy
but
he feels confident in what logan webb
can do and what he's doing in this game
he chuckled when we discussed the fact
that
you could save a pitcher like webb for
the next series which is a big one and
there's another whiff by the way that's
now a career high 17 for logan webb with
his swing and miss and we're seeing a
ton of it
but kepler said uh yeah we're gonna try
and win today's game i know it's the
dodgers and they just passed us for
first place in the nl west but they'll
worry about la tomorrow last few games
against them for the season come this
weekend
there's another whiff
this keeps adding to that record i'm
sure this one this won't stand at some
point in his career either he's got a
lot of years to pitch
[Applause]
but he's been awfully impressive today
with a three-pitch combination that is
as good as i've seen this year
[Applause]
and i know we're only in the fifth
inning but
i thought his last game in atlanta which
is as good as he could pitch and and
today he might he might surpass that
he's got lara in a 1-2 hole
even if you strike out if you're eric
lauer right now this is a win i mean
you've at least driven up the pitch
count a little bit
yeah deal you've seen laura in the box
this year a few times he doesn't he
looks like he's he can swing it a little
bit huh yeah he's comfortable he's had
some sack bunts he knows how to swing
the bat they work on batting practice
freezing
frozen make it
logan webb is baffling everyone right
now even the broadcasters
eight strikeouts this afternoon for mr
webb
trying to wipe away this losing skid for
the giants
on september 2nd 1990 the blue jays dave
steve was one out away from a no-hitter
as he got ready to face jerry brown of
the indians you could understand if
steve was thinking to himself
not again
you see dave steve had pitched five
one-hitters in his career already
including three in 1988 and two of those
were particularly heartbreaking in back
to back september starts steve had
gotten two outs in the ninth inning with
a no-hitter intact only to lose it so
there was the toronto right-hander on
the mound one out away again
and with jerry brown at the plate
dave steve's run of ninth inning
disappointments
finally ended
he has got a narrow hitter for dave
steve
the frustration is finally over
this is a moment you'll never ever
forget that's right fergie i won't
and you've had five cracks in it you got
it that many it was the first and only
no-hitter in toronto blue jays history
and after five one-hitters dave steve
finally had his no-hitter
[Music]
flight time and today we shine the light
on dawson wright who actually asked a
question for kevin gossman earlier
saying how impressive has logan webb
been but mr wright is balling with those
shades he makes baseball video essays on
a multitude of topics incurring
including current mlb events team
building analysis legendary stories from
baseball history today's really his day
i know he's got the angels uniform but
he's a giants fan his favorite memories
the 14 world series close to 12 million
views dawson thanks for hanging out with
us today and same with amy g it's a
pleasure to have you on today amy what
do you have for us on mauricio dubon
who's about to dig in yeah he's going to
step into the box and it's the first
time he's going to step into the box
with this club on a major league roster
since june 28th he's been down working
on his craft with the aaa sacramento
giants and i asked gabe kepler what he's
liked about the reports that he's
getting on dubon
he mentioned that he's improved his
chase percentage he's also improved his
swing percentage meaning he's he's
swinging less at bad pitches and he's
mostly gentlemen playing short stopped
of course today he's in center field but
gabe kepler was getting reports that
mauricio has put in a ton of work
in his downtime on the other positions
that he plays because he is a utility
player gave very impressed overall with
the stretch that dubon has had in
triple-a really looking for dabon to be
a shot in the arm for this offense today
gentlemen thanks amy 3 33 and 46 games
at aaa since last playing in mlb in late
july like you mentioned and
these first two pitches are actually a
perfect example sean he takes the first
two they're pretty close and earlier in
his career he thought he could swing at
anything super athlete but we're seeing
the patients progress
and that's what they need to see that's
how this lineup is is built they like
guys that swing at strikes like guys
that don't chase a lot they like guys
that try to do damage
with pitches in the strike zone and that
wasn't the case can on a consistent
basis when he was up with the giants the
first couple months of the season
and so we'll have to see moving forward
this is our first
chance to see him since he's been
recalled we'll have to see if that work
he put down in sacramento has paid off
he flew out to right in the second
inning
he's watched four pitches swings at that
one
and rides up a full count
he's up for wilmer flores who left
yesterday's game early
and they're calling it a grade one left
hamstring stream
he's on the 10 day injured list
[Applause]
lauer coming off a one two three fourth
inning
didn't you love that tim you're all
ready to go pay off pitch and then
hold up let me fix these padding gloves
yeah okay they're better they're
shifting on me
yeah i always find it interesting when
the umpire like calls time and and
points at who called the time don't be
mad at me be mad at this guy
and he rings him up
pitchers call for eric lauer and i'm
sure the giants brass would say okay
we'll take that a b
absolutely he saw six pitches and it was
a ball he should have been on first base
lauer gets the benefit of the call right
there but a nice at bat by mauricio de
bono and i know the end result wasn't
what he wanted it to be but
as you can see right there a couple
inches off the plate in
well the reason it was in full count the
first two pitches at the top of the zone
were actually pretty good so i'm
wondering if there's a conversation
going back there like you know angel
hernandez hey mate i miss those but i'll
give it yeah doubtful
well no because the first pitch to to
logan webb was better than the last
pitch to dubai
he threw he threw one a half an inch
inside and he got ball
logan was like why i will think i'll
take the strike he'd give mauricio the
ball
there's his strike but if you see i mean
you can tell i mean angel hernandez been
around a long time when a pitcher is
around the strike zone consistently
you're going to get the benefit of some
calls that are off the plate that's just
a fact
[Applause]
it's three and one to webb when you get
the umpire in wanting to call a strike
mode
like you've seen with logan webb in the
first five innings of this game
you're going to get some borderline
pitches
bouncing ball to short marias makes the
play
two down in the fifth
all season long on the mlb game of the
week
the power to vote for which standout
performer is going to receive this
gorgeous youtube player of the game
trophy that was mr walkoff from last
week jake myers in houston so stay tuned
later on we'll do the poll just like
we've been doing throughout the day
already and we're gonna hand out some
hardware in our post game show
immediately following the end of the
game we'll have a couple interviews
coming up 30 minutes dedicated to the
brewers and the giants after this one
concludes
so there's really a trophy i read that
on a little format it's already
downstairs on the field oh
and then it even it gets even better you
would have loved this because you know
sometimes there can be some monotony
in a season as austin slater watches a
strike on the outside corner with tugan
in the fifth
not only do you win a trophy but they
engrave your name on it brandon crawford
won when we did the giants and reds last
time around it was a big offensive
performance for the giants a few months
back and i think he was joking about it
with amy g we'll see if we can bring in
amy for a little more
on that
youtube trophy in a moment didn't they
score like 18 runs that game something
like that i know it was a high total
yeah it was everyone gets a trophy right
yeah yeah yeah
yeah you get one too
a little nubber
and lauer actually falls back but makes
the fadeaway throw in time let's see if
he's okay
it looks like he's okay but look like
sniper got him right there he was went
to turn and throw and then like all of a
sudden a cleat stuck or something and he
fell backwards
i was thinking is that the good
old-fashioned nba flop someone push him
there's no one there to call a foul
let's uh
right ankle little slip
throw his money that was money that was
right on the right on the money falling
back oh yeah a little hyper extension
ankle
going down sidearm right on the bag it's
a good play so we'll make sure he's okay
and ready to go for the next inning
because eric lauer is suddenly on some
kind of roll right now
he has retired eight in a row it's one
per side after five
[Applause]
[Music]
sammy long goes after the first pitch
and flips a hit into left center field
congratulations sammy long's got a big
league knock
it's that one pretty well out to left
center yastremski's gonna run it down
logan webb seventh strong tonight in
atlanta
crawford whacks one down the right field
line toward the corner that's a base hit
up against the wall it ricochets away
from conforto coming around third is
bryant he scores dickerson's heading
home the relay
and the giants have gone ahead on one
pitch from the bullpen
1-1 on the ground and nobody's there
into right field base hit pilar up with
the ball here comes jastremski the throw
is offline it goes right over the
catcher so darren ruff goes to second
the giants have gone ahead three to two
well it's that one to center field demo
all the way back and he's gonna watch it
it is gone off the apple two and one the
count
belt
deep left
and
that ball is gone
[Applause]
that's not a home run but it is a tough
play lindor not in time four hit night
[Music]
google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
google cloud is the official cloud
technology of major league baseball
there's a miss from webb to colton wong
third time through the order now we're
in the sixth that's pitch number 70 and
that's in there
scott brown sean estes tim dillard and
amy g with you this afternoon
wong searching for his first hit today
and he will not find it there brandon
belt will handle things himself
another ball on the ground
that's six ground ball outs for logan
webb today to go along with eight
strikeouts
so that's 14 of the 15 outs have been
via strikeout or ground ball
so
kind of as as advertised for logan webb
you always kind of look for the third
time through the lineup as well first
time they were over nine second time
through they were three for eight with
the walk
so we'll have to see how he navigates
this lineup the third time through the
order
we'll keep an eye on eric lauer
made a funny step at the end of his half
[Applause]
still made the play
we'll see if his ankle's okay
they'd love to get another couple
innings out of him especially after
brett anderson had to leave the game
early yesterday after just two innings
a comebacker went off his shoulder they
placed him on the 10-day injured list
and the bullpen had to cover seven
innings yesterday
and freddie peralta coming back tomorrow
he's not going to be on a very long
leash after not pitching for a couple
weeks so
they're probably not going to get a lot
of length out of him as well
maria's in the air shallow right here
comes slater
two down
hello again amy g hey scott i just
wanted to add on to what you said about
brandon crawford winning that trophy the
youtube player of the game he did
i don't know if he was joking about i
mean maybe he was dead serious but he
said he's got three gold glove trophies
and he was going to scoot them all over
to put the youtube trophy right there
front and center although it weighs i
mean over under like 12 pounds yeah so
you're gonna need to put you know find
the studs in the wall that's all that's
my advice
you can do some workout programs with
that i saw gabe kepler wearing the
dingers and deadlift shirt today there's
yelich with a bouncing ball to estrada
you can do a nice little workout with
the youtube trophy and brandon crawford
wants another we'll see if he helps his
team out
on offense as logan webb with another
shutdown inning 1-1 mid-six
swing and a miss and there's your first
down three-two on the way and there's
another strikeout for josh hayder
one-two on the right strike three game
over
he's got his mound opponent in a one-two
count and down he goes number 10 for
brandon woodruff
[Applause]
[Music]
and this one crushed all the way back
[Applause]
milwaukee
one-two pitch in the air left center
that'll get it done wong's gonna tag
aquino's throw comes in
cut off and we are tied
and he pulls one right field that is
down fair
in the score peterson
5-4 milwaukee
fly ball into right field hit well
garcia back at the track he leaped and
he makes the catch
hey
abby garcia pulls a home run back
there you go eric lauer is good to go
for the bottom of the sixth and his
teammate rowdy teles is our guy miked up
today
willie gets miked and doesn't tell
nobody and tries to sneak to sneak
attack some stuff
shut up willie they put that thing there
willie shut up
it's really his birthday what's the
camera i don't know what camera we're
looking at but everybody out there hey
it's my birthday today dawg his birthday
so
thank you please
hey happy birthday william thomas
milwaukee they love you out there
thank you rowdy i feel like we don't
just have rowdy teles miked up we have
willy adams miked up he knows where the
mic is at all time let's send it over to
amy g yeah well the other thing about
rowdy teles guys a die hard giants fan
growing up he's from the sacramento area
i got some time with him the other day
he said his very first baseball game was
that candlestick so those of us from
this area we know he was freezing for
sure he is a giants fan because his dad
grew up in san francisco he spent many a
father's day mother's day holiday here
at the yard he said his dad would take
him out of school early to get to a game
don't worry we won't tell anyone he
loves crook and kype and he said that he
attended at least one game of the 10 12
and 14 world series i had to ask who his
favorite giant was i'm so sorry sean
it's not you it was jt snow and of
course he loves barry bonds
that's awesome
chris bryant takes a pitch wide it's a
ball and a strike and i heard a story
the other day from ken rosenthal that in
2014 he was an instructional league with
the blue jays and he said i have to
leave a little bit early i have a family
hunting trip but actually before that
he went to a game
a giants world series contest so he just
forgot to include that bit of info sorry
guys i need to leave early family time
and giants time yeah
i can tell you though in the last three
games he hasn't been a big giant fan
mm-hmm
but it's kind of cool there's a lot of
guys come out of center for the
sacramento area
in the big leagues right now especially
at his high school elk grove or dylan
carlson's dad's the coach
bryant sends one to center
and jackie bradley jr commanding the
outfield today
[Applause]
there's a ton of alums
elk grove right elk grove yeah about 100
miles
pitching today from sacramento not from
elk grove high school from a different
high school and i think maybe rocklin or
high school but yeah there's there's a
ton of uh
sacramento big league products it's a
hotbed for baseball
ground out fly out for belt
on base 35 of the time this year he's at
a career-high 20 home runs this is his
11th season in the big leagues
looking at the back of the baseball card
for brandon belt going wait
11 years in the bigs
got a sweet swing big pop he's never
been at 20 no between some
injury-filled seasons and also the fact
that he plays in one of the more
cozy pitchers parks
you can see the big difference for him
this year is the breaking ball all of a
sudden
he's
just nailing breaking pitches
i mean you wonder how a change is made
so late in your career to be able to do
that is he
you know messing around with a pitching
machine that's throwing breakers at him
he's actually always been pretty good
down in the zone
and slices his bat in half and goes to
left and drops a base hit
and a fastball down in the zone
that's where you give him a chance and
even though he did break his bat it
allows him to get the barrel to bat to
this baseball if you watch
eric lauer it's down and away it's not
it you have to go bell and up with
brandon bell to get him out but it's
tough to execute that pitch every time
now you could probably throw belt high
top with his own fastballs and the best
he's going to do is pop it up but if you
miss down in the zone that's what he's
waiting for and he usually does a lot of
damage now with the off speed stuff he's
been hitting a lot of home runs against
the off speed stuff down slow but that's
kind of been his mo his whole career and
it does blow your mind to think he's
never hit 20 home runs with him not much
power as he has had as he has
not to his defense he's playing in a
ballpark where he hits a lot of balls
out to right center in in visiting
ballparks here triples alley it's a long
way out there he's
he's been a victim of triples alley
probably more times than anybody
in a giant uniform
that's skied by ruff
bradley jr
measures out number two
let's finish up that
last poll that we unveiled about an
inning ago top three starters scariest
in a postseason series the brewers take
it was close with their division rival
45-35
that's fair brewers fans weighing in big
today
i mean the more i see it as brewer team
the the more i like them the more i feel
like that just balance they they have
such good starting pitching as we've
talked about great bullpen great defense
great bench offense scores enough runs
tyro estrada to the first pitch center
field
bradley jr
getting a lot of good work out there
yeah craig council's club is serious
they've taken the first three in this
series that wraps up today still tied at
one
[Applause]
that ball is hit a mile to right
heading for san francisco bay
it is whack
five to three giants lamont way junior
and there's the hungry
mother
emily
so the fans everybody's standing now
that the giants have been playing catch
up all night long
as a high drive to right is it fair down
to nine
[Applause]
can you believe it
and they all score
including the man who hit the ball
the giants have come from seven to
nothing behind
and yostremski has put them ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
get ready for this listen to mlb's
podcast to hear the latest analysis from
insiders across the league and exclusive
in-depth interviews with baseball's
biggest stars subscribe now at mlb.com
podcasts and
well the mlb ballpark app of course will
complete your next visit to the ballpark
buy and manage game tickets redeem
offers access exclusive content and much
more download the ballpark app today
do it
nailed it
billy do it that was good i didn't get
one of those pieces of paper
gotta plug something else your time will
come fouled off the end of the bat of
avasale garcia that was perfect sean you
know we haven't done that on youtube but
i felt like today was the day i just
feel very cozy and comfortable with my
friends here sean estes and tim dillard
having a good time i can't wait for
dilly's read
it's going to be epic i mean i can read
pretty decent i mean like
that's not
the hardest thing for me but
i tell you what we need we need to talk
about lauer after that play the inning
before last and then coming back out on
a 10 pitch
inning well he had enough rest i think
he was in the clubhouse for a good 20
minutes after that no
we didn't get to see it but
we were waiting for lauer to take them
out i'm wondering if he went in or got
taped up didn't have time uh logan webb
threw a seven pitch inning so that's
what they're doing they're doing tit for
tat back and forth and
yeah i wonder if he did get taped up but
he looked good everything looked the
same did not look yeah i didn't miss a
beat
this is a good old-fashioned pitching
match up
and i say that not just because of the
score
but because of the way they've been
economical there's logan webb just not
wasting pitches
it's his ninth strikeout
it's 1-1 in the seventh and rowdy teles
has more for us
in a moment
rowdy's mic'd up we're routing we're
waiting for rowdy actually come on yeah
rowdy's not being rowdy
say something
so that's nine on the day for webb he
pumps another
strike he's mellow rowdy right now
um
that's the hat trick for garcia by the
way yeah and
so jase peterson is one for two he had
the rbi hit for milwaukee in the fourth
odds court to see a fanduel
who said over who said under when we did
this earlier
well i'll give him the the listeners one
guess we have a brewer and a giant so
yeah
so far the giant is winning they are
under three
yeah i don't gamble a lot i'm not a
betsman i'm like i'm a guest man that's
what i did i guess i guessed over
there's still time
i mean this isn't over i just wanted to
update everyone
two one to peterson now two and two
this is the one guy that has helped your
chances of going over so far he's got
the one rbi for the the brewers
two out situation in the fourth inning
coming off a monster month of august too
and he was great last month
he does that very well
stays in his zone
last month i looked up the positions he
played six total for jase peterson
including a pitching performance
he got on the bond paw
how'd he look billy looked pretty good
looked like a position player on the
mound
[Laughter]
and another strikeout victim
double digit punch outs
for logan webb rowdy toles are you there
i think brandon crawford is one of the
best league games in baseball
we win a couple world series and go a
bunch of old gloves world you know
see i told you check out his cleats dude
dude his city connect ones
were painted on and he said i think it's
souls by sir it's free marketing but
they're sold by sir you get that on the
mic uh
his those are sick
sick well now they're gonna have to hook
you up with a pair rowdy
oh
you definitely know where brandon
crawford is on the field yeah he knows
which shoe goes on which foot too
that helps out brandon crawford yeah
that's my name
here's vogelback you know how the solid
shoe game we saw before the game was
gabe kepler
i wonder if there's like a contest going
on who can have the the most orange
on their feet dave kepler was on top of
his game for sure
if logan webb picks up another strike
here on daniel vogelbot
not only will it be another one two
three for him
it would be a career-high
11 strikeouts he has matched his
career-high mark at the moment
he's had 88 pitches you'd think he's got
at least one more inning in him now at
least
depends on how this at-bat goes but yeah
you'd think if he could get through this
inning at 90 pitches that
depending on how the eighth inning went
how the game's going i mean it still is
a tie game yeah you
may have a chance to pitch deeper than
that
i think you got to listen to the game i
mean when you look at someone like
gabe kepler who played
got now on the other side of things just
like craig counsel you got to read the
game and what is the game telling you
right now i mean if he can go 110
pitches you've got to put him back out
there it's not so much a pitch count
thing other than the game's telling you
you got to leave them out there the
stuff is still nasty still getting
swinging miss
payoff
we'll do it again keep in mind
they're asking him to be the stopper
today too
the giants have lost four in a row
they've lost four in a row but they've
won 12 out of the last 13 with logan
webb on the mound now i mentioned it
before the game that the one loss was
against the brewers and though he
pitched pretty well in milwaukee the
brewers were able to get him late in
that game winning extra innings
that's smoked off the bat of vogelback
and it's gonna bounce up against the
right field wall he's heading for second
here comes the throw and they got him
austin slater on the money
that's the big leagues right there oh my
goodness
wow
he was going he was he's
he put his head down and started running
right out of the gate that was just a
good play off the wall good throw right
there
you watched the throw you watched the
play
plays it perfect off the wall
bogobox sniffing the double out of the
box but slater comes up fields it clean
throws a strike one hopper right on the
back crawford puts the quick tag down
that is textbook perfection right there
i think he kind of took it he took his
mind off getting a second about halfway
through and then tried to pick it up but
tough to slow that big body down though
isn't it yeah well he's been battling
some leg stuff so okay
yeah 536 players with a sprint speed
clock this year and vogelback's at 512.
slater knew it
hang on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is william thomas goes opposite field in
the night and the brewers lead it in
colorado
[Applause]
one ball no strikes on adamus swinging a
drive deep left field
tied
willie adamus strikes again
against the colorado rockies
and the brewers come back down four
nothing
adamus in the air right center
ball's hit well mariznick on the run and
it is up and out it's a grand slam
the first of the year for the brewers
willie and thomas again
and this ballpark is lit up
[Applause]
[Applause]
mlb originals season two is live on
youtube with new episodes every week see
your favorite players and learn more
about the game you love on youtube.com
mlb
brandon crawford takes a strike on the
inside corner from eric lauer
so we've stretched
and we still see a 1-1 score
what a series it's been between the
brewers and giants that wraps up today
and then san francisco
moves on to face the dodgers this
weekend at home right here in oracle
park and the brewers actually head home
back to milwaukee they'll face the
cardinals for three
and then the phillies come to town
there's tyler rogers gives you a
different look a little bit of a dilly
look
sidearm side hander gotta love those
guys love it
crawford cassalli dubon here in the
seventh and yes
just 76 pitches so far today for eric
lauer
his longest outing this year was against
pittsburgh july 3rd where he went six
and a third so this right here is kind
of uncharted territory but he's earned
it i i think you got to leave him out
there continually i i don't know why the
giants would have somebody up personally
i think we got to go with logan webb
when guys are dealing
just let them go out there and deal
they've put on all the work they've set
up hitters throughout the entire game to
where the next time they come out there
they have a plan so
i think it's just precautionary in case
a spot comes up
exactly right dilly exactly what's going
on if web spot comes up where a giant
gets on base
his spot will come up so
cap's looking at this may be the only
opportunity to to score a run
he did it yesterday yeah if he can get
someone in scoring position we've seen
him do it all year he'll pull the
trigger early in the game
oh look at that oh
that's it maybe they're saying
congratulations you got another one yeah
no probably not
oh man 92 pitches i mean that's a day
well maybe caps just feeling that you
know they're gonna get somebody on base
here wishful thinking
he's not a guy either that'll get
somebody up get him hot and then not
bring him in the game either
[Applause]
that's casalli after crawford
lowers 3-2
out of play
34-year-old brandon crawford
i mean outside of that first pitch of
the game that's the only run that the
giants scored and eric lowers pitched as
well as brandon as logan webb the only
thing is is the strikeouts aren't there
the strikeouts look prettier right with
with logan webb and his dominance but
lauer has been super efficient there's a
strikeout he heard you sean
[Applause]
what's that high fastball once again the
invis what do you call it the invisi
cutter invisi cutter
it is a lot of swing throughs today with
that pitch and a lot of fly ball outs
like you mentioned
not a lot that weak contact
dilly it's all you yeah the postseason
race is on mlb.tv now only 26.99 catch
all the action live or on demand plus
mlb big inning restrictions apply visit
mlb.tv for details i'm going home kirk
casalli to center and jackie bradley jr
circles around it
two away yeah that was
perfection yeah
i've read it seven times
since the break
yeah that youtube video i watched on how
to be a good broadcaster is paying off
right now
whoever put that together yeah
beautifully done
another fly ball out dilly longest
outing of the season for eric lauer and
you know what it comes because of early
contact that right there's another first
pitch out
he has
three of those four of those i believe
on the day
i mean with a guy that throws a lot of
fastballs and does pound the strike zone
as a hitter that's what you should do
right go up there be aggressive if it's
a pitch that you feel like that you can
drive
but you can tell that fastball up in the
zone plays a lot harder than it really
is
you're seeing a lot of fly balls but
they're not balls that are squared up
their balls are hit straight up in the
air which shows me that the hitters
think that they're on time for it they
think that they're going to get barrel
and they just missed the barrel they hit
the top part of the bat well you set the
tone early it's almost like ben sheets
back in the day throwing strikes early
it's all about
filling up the zone so a hitter that is
like okay well this guy's not throwing
any balls what are you gonna do be
patient you're gonna walk up there it's
gonna be o2 before you know it so you
gotta jump in the box batting gloves
tight bad on your shoulder ready to
swing out of the gate because you've set
that tone in that foundation throughout
the innings both pitchers have done that
remarkably today
yeah you get hitters in swing mode
before they even step in the box but
that's the thing that this giant team
has prided themselves on is working
counts making the pitcher work getting
them out of the game early especially
the starters but they've had difficult
time with pitchers that throw strikes
with good stuff in the zone this year
many guys that attack them that don't
run from them that don't nibble guys are
aggressive with good stuff
those are the guys because that that
makes them go into swing mode yep
well
one thing that this brewers staff as a
whole does is their stuff plays in the
zone they're willing to throw strikes
and get swings and misses
uncomfortable swings weak contact in the
zone
they don't have to rely on that pitch
hey oh he chased it it was way over
there and he chased it it's like no i'm
trying to give you a good strike
it helps to have as many guys in this on
this in this rotation and in the bullpen
that can strike you out too
another 3-2 count for dubon today and
this one is skyed
and comes bradley jr and the gold glover
is all over it
with a little leap
colten wong with a smile
three up three down in the seventh eric
lauer has been fantastic today for
milwaukee preserving this one one game
through seven
maze was a baseball genius who
positioned the giants defense and gained
plan four and against pitchers if you're
the leader of a ball club you have to
make sure that you are in control but
the true genius of willie mays is found
in his nickname the say hey kid
ted williams gary carter ken griffey jr
and willie mays all hall of fame players
who earned the highest nickname of honor
kid
whether playing stickball in harlem at
20 winning the world series at 23
knocking in the winning run of a world
series game with his last hit at 42 or
turning 90 years old this year willie
mays
willie mays honestly original purest
version of baseball that we hold so dear
that this
is a kiss game it is designed to be fun
when played well and with joy
baseball is never better
[Applause]
still 1-1 as we climb into the eighth
inning and document the story of
christian yelich with back-to-back nl
batting titles an mvp on the resume
uh big time i guess you could call it
lifetime contract with the brewers
during his career career worst 205 and
then the career worst slugging line this
season but
craig council his manager said he's been
on fire lately so we're just looking for
the confidence level of anyone
that's participating right now can he
regain his mvp form in october 100
feeling good not great i'm worried and
then
a daily special here here for the nachos
hot dog i'm here for the hot dog
yesterday after the game i walked down
the parking lot there's a lady selling
hot dogs wrapped in bacon
so that did that happen did you did you
go there yeah i did well it was just in
my way and i'm like well i have to do
this just to get through yeah
and
this is a guy that you're gonna need to
break down even though
sean's been handling the giant pictures
for us tim you made a change at one
point and decided to
pitch like tyler rogers or i should say
rogers decided to pitch like tim dillard
he's in the game he's one of the best
relievers in the sport and he also is a
high usage guy i mean this is someone
who's led the nl in appearances each of
the last two seasons his first two full
seasons as he takes over for logan webb
who was elite this afternoon on the
mound well that's the side effect of
throwing
down there submarine action even sidearm
a little bit less stress on the arm
really it comes down to having a plan
against lefties right you your whole
craft is built to get righties out but
we saw it the other night we're seeing
it right here doing a great job
against left-handed hitters
you see tyler rogers throwing out of the
shoes right there
austin slater recommended him wearing
white shoes this spring said hey you
throw from down there it could cause a
distraction to the hitter ball comes out
of your shoes
why not use it to your advantage and
he's had him he's been rocking them all
year long and he's had another great
season dear agent i need white shoes and
then red laces
the brighter the white the better please
there's no rule against that nope
not yet anyway
we might have just given it away
yeah but it's so funky because it's such
a different look to the hitters
there you go polar opposites right there
for different reasons the neon orange
yeah
one for show one for effectiveness well
you have the high top from brandon
crawford i mean that's he's got to plant
and go i mean that actually probably
helps with ankle support
luke maylie foul ball
[Applause]
we also saw something from rogers
against bradley that you don't see as
frequently as you do for most relievers
despite the
excellent era this year for tyler rogers
the strikeouts per nine innings is among
the lowest
for a relief pitcher it's just not his
thing also killing worms taking numbers
he's contact guy
makes him put him play weekly
but look at him go or he strikes you out
but yeah you're right he's not a strike
out of any guy you'd think coming from
down under he's got the little frisbee
almost the slider that looks like it
takes off he'll throw it up and into
lefties it looks like it almost rises
this one right here
might have been a sinker
doesn't throw hard i mean it's hard to
throw hard from down there right dilly i
mean
not many guys can throw 90 from that
angle well one time once your
arm gets when your hand gets past your
shoulder going down it's really hard to
get any force behind it when i did
sidearm i made sure that the ball was
just above my shoulder so i could keep
some of that velocity but it's all about
what you're trying to do he's not trying
to blow a guy away with heat he's doing
it with 8283 but he's playing off of his
off speed stuff
and just the funkiness of it because
you may go an entire season not face a
guy like this
and for you to buy into it walk up there
and go you know what i'm just going to
throw my stuff because i'm just going to
rely on these guys not having any
practice and no reference point for what
i'm doing out here
this is rowdy teles pin [ __ ] for
eric lower whose day is done there's
that pitch that's up in the zone that
almost looks like it rises when it gets
to the plate that's physically
impossible to do but
when you come from that angle it does
when it gets to the top of the zone it
holds its plane rather than sinks
is rowdy still mark mike for the event
oh yes he is we're gonna get some word
from rowdy
at some point we'll turn that audio
around and
get his thoughts
[Applause]
another thing that rogers does so well
too he does stay out of the middle part
of the zone and i've seen him this year
a few times especially against teams
that have seen him more than others
teams in the nls the dodgers padres
diamondbacks rockies teams that see him
like two three times in a series they
start to get better swings against him
but the first time like you mentioned
billy
he's got to be tough at that
oh wow
there's that up and in
slider takes off
nasty
that thing was sailing to the bay
he strikes out the side
tyler rogers everyone
the big right-hander with a handlebar
mustache
up until 81 they needed that closer they
needed the confidence that came with the
guy like fingers at the end of ball
games raleigh fingers was and is the
best when he signed with the milwaukee
brewers we knew that when games were
called upon for his services that our
chances of winning dramatically
increased
comes in
and gets his man
when he came into a game you knew the
game was over
that was the way we felt
raleigh fingers the ace reliever over
milwaukee brewers
and fingers never missed a beat
dominating the american league
81 was the year that raleigh won the mvp
in cy young and i do not believe over
the course of 162 games raleigh fingers
made a bad pitch
he was also the fireman of the year and
winner of the roll age relief man award
both his talent and unique style soon
brought him a cult following in
milwaukee raleigh the magnificent
with his curling handlebars
[Applause]
the history and performance of this man
raleigh fingers has been clearly
documented he's one of the best at his
trade
this copyrighted telecast is presented
by authority of the office of the
commissioner of baseball and may not be
reproduced or retransmitted in any form
in the accounts and descriptions of this
game may not be disseminated without
express written consent
scott braun sean estes tim dillard and
amy g joining us right now
all right gentlemen well hearts are
breaking all over the city of san
francisco as ron watas who's coming up
the steps here shortly to coach third
base he is the longest tenured coach in
san francisco giants history and he
announced he will be hanging it up after
this season he will no longer be a
full-time coach come 20-22 now to put
this in perspective he's been with the
giants organization for 34 years 24 of
those seasons right here with the bigly
club and i talked to the hitting coach
donnie ecker who said ron woodis has
been a true sounding board for this
coaching staff they're a very young
staff that has come in after the bruce
bochy reign and ron has been this pillar
of wisdom and experience and knowledge
donnie ecker referred to him as a human
google he will definitely be missed he's
absolutely beloved by all in san
francisco gentlemen
hats off to you ron
what a career
what a guy
and he will be missed
out there at third base
he said a little more
life balance hanging with the fam
at this point
you know when you're part of a coaching
staff
it's the same grind as the players
you're on the road
half to summer
special individual special coach
lamont way junior pinshitter here in the
home eighth
and that one he got under
christian yelich fighting some sun and
finding out number one
so can you give us
anything good on ron lotus as we check
out devon williams is in the game mr
airbender change-up aficionado but
yeah you talk about special there's a
pretty special picture right here
yeah this guy knows that
all around right now yeah a lot of
special everyone everyone being special
no i you look at specifically at devon
williams right now the the airbender we
talked about it uh on the pre-game show
but you know what logan webb's got a
great change up it's kind of coming back
to the forefront across baseball but if
you look specifically at devin williams
in his last 31 appearances he's thrown
29 innings only giving up one earned run
that is a .31 era that'll play
yeah that'll play and back to ron motis
i mean
he was my manager in double a he's my
manager in aaa one manager of the year
both those years won the divisions both
those years uh you knew that he was
destined for the big leagues and then he
got to
dusty baker and had him on his coaching
staff right after that and he's been
with the club ever since he's just
through his fourth manager the longest
tenured coach
nice change up there but you could i
could go on and on about ron lotus and
what he's meant to this organization and
just the wealth of knowledge and it's
unfortunate that he hasn't been been a
manager in his career up to this point i
know he's had a few interviews for
whatever reason he hasn't got that
opportunity but he's filled all kinds of
different roles with the giants and
he's just a stand-up guy and they're
definitely gonna miss him
i mean i'm sure he'll be around in some
capacity that's
that's yet to be determined
but
he won't be in the dugout on the in the
clubhouse but just like you mentioned
the sounding board for a lot of the
other coaches
and the players love them the veteran
guys gush over him crawford bell posey
the guys that have been with them for
the longest amount of time
crawford right away went out and did a
goat on twitter after he found out that
he was going to step down next year
so uh well respected
a staple in the organization and we just
showed you some defensive swapping
peterson to right fields
marias moves over from short to third
and then comes the showman
williams
and the birthday boy yeah happy birthday
willie
should i tell him that i wore his helmet
in the dugout before he gets out for
stretch i have a picture to document it
yeah
that's my bad well to see if it was
lucky or not
i'm sure he'll get it bad at this game
yeah we'll find out
there's slater gone fishing
yeah a lot of guys go fishing at this
pitch right here one of the best pitches
in all of baseball maybe the best pitch
in all of baseball well it sets itself
apart when you talk about guys with
really good fastballs really good
cutters really good curveball maybe the
changeup is special in that way because
he throws it 86 miles an hour and he
knows he's going to throw it and he
knows that the batter knows it's coming
and so he still goes out there and
throws it
that's more than just confidence in the
pitch that's got to be courage because
you're going out there going hey i know
you know it's coming and i'm going to
throw it anyway
what's crazy about his change up and
like you mentioned the hitters know that
they're gonna see it he throws it with
great arm speed
but a lot like trevor hoffman you know
coming into closed games for his career
hall of fame career yeah he had a good
fastball to go with it but the hitters
knew that they were he was going to they
were going to see the change up there's
such a difficult pitch to to if you
locate it it's still tough to square up
it's got to be up in the zone to be able
to hit it and he locates it down better
than anybody he rarely ever seems to
make a mistake with the change-up
i think he was trying to balance it out
with a fastball early on because he was
struggling with that feel but when he
has a feel for it he can just throw it
every single pitch we've seen it over
and over again
and i think the reason it's such a
mind-bender the airbender to the hitter
is because they it's it takes you back a
notch on how it how much it moves how it
starts up they think you made a mistake
up in the zone it ends up in the dirt
just an incredible pitch
yanked another fastball to chris bryant
he's done that twice in this a b and you
wonder sometimes two pitchers they they
don't forget
certain players at bats if you know
they've had success against them or
if they've hit a home run off of yet and
i know that he's faced chris brown a lot
being in the nl central for so long
maybe that plays into how you approach a
guy you almost you know mind trick
yourself sometimes into believing that
they're
gonna hit that change up maybe some sort
of edge yeah some edge because they've
seen it so many times and maybe he's
squared up his changeup in the past so
now he's seeing a couple fastballs
and that's ball four four pitch walk for
chris bryant two out base runner for the
giants in the eighth
you know sometimes you just when you get
behind
especially really good hitters
especially in one run ball games late in
the game you don't just throw a get me
over you're better off just walking the
guy hit the reset button on the nintendo
and try for the next batter
devin williams is
in the eighth inning roll
has come to the forefront of going you
know what if it takes me 30 pitches
that's fine as long as you put up a zero
they don't care how many pitches you
throw it's like yeah who cares yeah he
might have pushed the reset button but
this is a guy in this whole giant lineup
that has the ability to square up david
williams based on the fact he does like
soft down in the zone
next up brandon belt
that messes up and because of that he's
going to make devin williams go away
from his strength and you got to get
brandon belt up with high fast balls and
and above this above his hands with high
velocity
but if that's not one of your strengths
then you're kind of playing right into
his hand
yeah i like how you said last at-bat you
got to go above the belt for belt
i don't know if you meant to do that you
have that stashed away did not no
i was waiting for that
there's a tough strike
for belt
not doing much with that pitch you're
not if you're gonna if you swing at it
make contact you're gonna you're gonna
roll over it to the right side
and it's going to be a ground ball out
so you might as well just take it
wait for a mistake but to be able to
locate that airbender like that as well
that's just unfair
he won nl reliever of the month
in august
[Applause]
it's two and one belt by the way
has five home runs against the brewers
this year it's a quarter of his power
against the team they don't face often
obviously and face a team like this
seven times for the season
and brandon bell has punished brewer
pitching and you can't say that about
many hitters in all of baseball this
year
and he's punished right-handed hitters
or pitchers as far as the home runs go
16 of his 20 against righties
there's a big about in this game based
on the match up where we are one run
game get head in the count
brandon belt you can almost eliminate
the fastball right now because devin
williams has a manel to locate it
people are booing a pic to first yeah
yeah
not allowed to do that no
not on the road you know that
do they realize that 90 feet's pretty
big deal right now
and chris bryant can steal a base
[Applause]
2-1 he's running chris bryant for second
and he is out
[Applause]
luke maylie delivers
and willia domes slaps on the tag
oh they're gonna give that a look
what a throw by melee it looked like
brian he had a great jump looked like he
was gonna steal that bag easily
and he can run he's faster than he looks
i mean he six five but he can get after
it
he can scoot
well william's not trying to hold him
too close as far as being quick to the
plate he's more focused on trying to
make the pitch at the plate
here's your money shot
is he
i think he's safe wow that's close it's
a tough angle right there we need to see
this one right here
unless the umpire
blocks it out
this is being reviewed officially by the
way
adamus
put the glove on the left side of bryant
i mean
the crowd obviously looks at the angle
that we just saw and
i'll tell you what the brewer's best
friend right now might be alex tosi the
second base umpire
but i guarantee you they have a better
angle in new york do they they need to
share that
share it with the world
we need the overhead drone angle yeah we
need to know what's going on here
it might not be enough it needs to be
conclusive to overturn what was on the
field
which is out
are we confident that he's safe here
well in one angle he's touching him high
and then it goes down
so you have to assume on the angle where
you can see the hand he's tagging him
early see on the top of the number
the crowd's going safe
new york's got many more angles than
we're seeing right now so
this might be the best one
and that's still hard because you can't
see where the hand comes in because
adamus's body's in the way
this one you can't see because the glove
is
now it's gone and then the other one you
can't see because the umpire
but it's a big deal because it's a 3-1
count on brandon belt you have a runner
in scoring position
i know the giants crowd does not think
it's close it's pretty close
yeah it's funny you always hear that oh
it would you think it was close well
yeah of course it's closed that's why
we're reviewing it
it wasn't closed we would be we'd be
we'd be moving on to
the ninth inning and that's why it's
taking a little more time i mean
sometimes it's easy this one is
not a gimme
all right
here we go and the conclusion he's safe
chris brian swipes a bag
i think he hurt himself fellas pinky
he jammed it
got to keep an eye on chris bryant now
he's got the oven mitt that he puts on
not quite as big as a lot of guys go
with but he was wiggling that pinky
finger
as soon as he got that brace off and he
took his batting glove off as well
and was checking out his pinky finger
last year he spent some time on the
injured list with a left finger issue
oh now the crowd is pumped
leveraging the count for bell and he
walks
well what that did is it opened up that
base and so yeah there's a picture dilly
you're thinking like all right if you if
you got a guy in first base i'm gonna
probably pitch to you but now you're at
second i got an open base and i'm not
giving in yeah good job good steal i'll
just put this guy over here at first
i mean sometimes that's the best case
scenario and it you know he's been in
this eighth inning role all season long
got so much experience last year got
rookie of the year so for devon williams
it's now just to kind of slow things
down i think they kind of freeze the
kicker moment with the long time review
in the play
uh even right there if he's
uh you know a quick easy like they look
at it in five seconds and go oh yeah
he's safe and then you continue the
inning they probably wouldn't affected
that pitch so much but when you just
start hanging out on the field i think
that's one of the wrong things about
replay is you kind of overlook the
pitcher just yeah he gets a throw to a
catcher and stuff but it's it totally
disrupts the moment of what you're
trying to do it's one more thing that a
pitcher has to overcome
and i just don't think that devin
williams really loved the matchup
against brandon belt anyway you saw him
go away from his strength with his which
is his change up knowing that brandon
belt strength is soft down in the zone
so i think he was going to be careful
with brandon belt regardless and not a
bat but
as soon as chris bryant stole second
base it made it pretty easy
darren ruff loves left-handed pitching
and we'll see if he has
the ability to crack the code against
one of the toughest righties in baseball
[Applause]
devil wins looking in like that could
have been a strike
a little bit better frame job that might
he might have caught that bottom part of
the zone
[Applause]
we saw a similar location called for a
strike
earlier in this inning
bryant on second belt on
first the giants have one run today and
it came all the way back in the opening
inning
first pitch for the offense austin
slater socked a homer
[Applause]
are we gonna see any fast balls this ab
i feel like this could just be change up
city
i think you're right
[Applause]
giants looking for that big hit they
haven't had it
it's been a while
[Applause]
rough blast one left field and it's down
in the corner here comes bryant the
giants grab the lead it's 2-1
darren ruff comes through against devon
williams
with a double
well you saw the graphic runners in
scoring positions of giant sport for the
last 42 o for two today
but darren ruff been so clutch this year
sits on one pitch gets the change up in
a zone that he likes and drives that
ball out to left field and that's been
the big hit that they have been looking
for all series
mr clutch does it again
mr williams gives up his first earned
run since june 23rd that was a while ago
it's september folks
[Applause]
and you saw chris bryant going down into
the tunnel
i'm wondering if that slide into second
base didn't do something to his hand
have to wait and see on that one but
nonetheless
giants take take the lead might be the
first lead they've had in this series
well they had the lead
in the first inning just briefly right
austin slater with the home run but then
the brewers caught up in the fourth
it's
been a series dominated by milwaukee
giants out in front
and it's up to tyro estrada this would
be some nice insurance
big cut and a miss on the changeup
two in scoring position it's belt at
third
rough the big man at
[Applause]
second yeah like you mentioned scott
outside of that first inning slater's
home run now this the first second lead
now of the series they had not had a
lead in the first three games of the
series
it's tough to play from come behind
especially against this team
i mean
i saw his comment one of our youtube
creators brewer's got to be the toughest
team to hit against in the eighth and
ninth crazy one-two punch with williams
and hader
the pitch looks a little bit off the
plate
dilly you can attest to this i mean box
burger and cousins and
i'm missing someone else down there
they're no joke either strickland
oh yeah oh he's strickland that guy yeah
[Applause]
i think we're i think where
devin williams ran into trouble was
trying to get a read on what ruff's
approach was right there hit those first
pitch change up ball takes it next pitch
change up
strike he took it you didn't really know
what his approach was is he trying to
stay back and maybe hit something on the
right side is he what's he trying to do
here and i think he sat on the change up
down and in i mean i think that's the
only way that you hit that pitch and
keep it fair i think we've seen a lot of
times a guy that sells out for it he's
going to hit it 500 feet way back up
way way foul but for him to keep that
fair that's a good piece of hitting
[Applause]
02 on estrada
real talk question dilly were you ever
distracted by the mascot i mean
like right now i am lucille's been
putting on a show for the entire inning
austin kleczka said lucille devin
williams ultimate weakness
he's been just dancing up a storm right
behind home plate left side of your
screen
hello lou we see you giants are pulling
out all the stops trying to win the game
get the mascot involved whatever works
did that ever distract you did you ever
see a mascot like that back there yeah
i've come set with the famous san diego
chicken coaching first base so i mean i
give it i get it
i remember pitching in montreal and you
could see
behind home plate they had this plexi
glass for people you could sit and their
mascot's name was a yupi yep and up used
to sit down there and make all these
because you could see there was actually
a tv back there too it was kind of a
distraction because you could see
yourself pitching
uh through the plexiglass but you pieced
to go back there and make all these hand
gestures and and try to distract you as
a pitcher and if you let you can let it
get to you if you focused on it
usually a pretty tunnel vision out there
that's two and two now against estrada i
think the late great tommy losordo
gotten a little little brawl with up at
one point
who was distracting the squad for the
dodgers back in the day
yeah tommy deserved it
[Applause]
estrada with a deep drive
left field oh he got all of that won
tyro estrada for three it's 5-1 san
francisco
muscle up young man his fourth of the
year
well he got the big hit from darren ruff
and that might have been the knockout
blow right there by tyrostrata and
that's the whole next man up mentality
for this giant ball club
tyrostrada gets the start today
faces a tough ride in williams and ends
up hitting the ball at a ballpark
three-run home run
to add to that league leading home run
total for the san francisco giants
some of those change-ups you kind of got
on the side of it right there that one
had more of the horizontal movement
rather than the downward movement but
sometimes that happens a career high
four runs allowed by devin williams the
giants with a late punch
it's 5-1
[Applause]
it has never been done before in the
alcs
where a club has fallen behind in the
first two games and then come back to
win it county stadium was rocking that
night from a jam-packed county stadium
the american league championship on the
line
three to two we've got the bases loaded
cecil cooper hitting cecil cooper comes
to the plate with opportunity staring
him in the face
mr cooper
one run home
[Applause]
without question the biggest moment in
my life
[Applause]
so it came down to a future hall of
famer against a newly christened closer
what a poetic way to reach the world
series
short he throws it's
have over the american league
milwaukee you have a world series
[Applause]
what an eighth inning for san francisco
darren ruff with the rbi double to vault
the giants in front two to one and then
tyro estrada with a three-run trick
off devon williams and now holby milner
in the game first pitch swinging is
brandon crawford
and a little bloop right into colton
wong's glove side retired but the giants
put up a four spot a career high four
runs allowed by devon williams and only
the second time he's given up a home run
against a right-handed hitter it's tyro
estrada to save the day and we'll see if
the giants can wrap this one up
they're a strike away from winning the
world series great finish the game seven
the madison bumgarner all that he has
done to help the giants get here you
know it was fitting that he was on the
mountain does he have one more out pitch
hitting losing wasn't an option
for him
when that pop-up went up it seemed like
it stayed in the air for
an eternity i never been so nervous on
an infield pop-up especially when in the
foul
territory sandoval
territory underneath it i see three
balls
i just concentrate you know
catch the ball don't miss them
try constantly catch it don't get too
excited sandoval down the line in foul
brown he's got plenty of room
it was unreal it was unreal
[Music]
and the giants have won the world series
again for the third time in the last
five years the san francisco giants are
the champions of the baseball world
[Applause]
hey visit the giant san francisco
no visit the san francisco giants same
thing official youtube channel to watch
behind the scenes content highlights and
learn more about your favorite players
subscribe to youtube.com
giants and do it today so you never miss
a video sounds pretty cool
yeah yeah what you got the brewers
youtube page is the best place to go
behind the scenes with the team just
visit youtube.com
brewers to subscribe oh yeah milwaukee
brewers thing you can do
i can do better what a showdown just now
man yeah i think he got me on that one i
had to repeat the giants a couple times
it's tense in here
well giants fans are very happy at the
moment after that eighth inning and a
blast from tyro estrada lamont wade jr
playing out in left field now
for the giants
and there's jake mcgee
their closer going for number 30 on the
season 29 saved so far this year and
for all those change-ups we've seen from
devon williams you're mostly going to
see fastballs from this man the
left-hander with a standout season this
year for san francisco
first three in the order for the brewers
non-safe situation i should mention it's
a four-run game yeah he hasn't pitched
in a week last time he pitched was on
august 25th so he'll be well rested
you'll see that lively fastball now he
won't pitch more
than two days in a row he's he's only a
back-to-back guy they'll never use him
in three straight days but he needs to
get some work in non-save situation you
expected to see mcgee and what you're
going to see is you're going to see
about 98 fastballs
wong up the middle base hit to start the
ninth
his first hit of the day and maurice
will follow
that's wong's mo right there loves to
hit lefties hits lefties better than
righties which is strange for a
left-handed hitter but he's been
struggling of late so that was actually
a gift for him to come in and
for whatever reason feels way more
comfortable facing lefties at this
moment in the season
yeah man jake and jake mcgee was happy
to see a lefty in the box they're 10 for
his lat they're last 60 off of him so he
has his way with lefties and colton wong
won that battle
something's got to give
and it did
huang on first
maria's had the double in the fourth and
he scored the lone tally for milwaukee
today
and you ask how a closer
can throw one pitch in essence
being a fastball and still get it done
and the fact is that mcgee has one of
those fastballs if you ask hitters that
it has plays a lot harder than it really
is he thrown 94.95 but to a hitter
and 96. it'll especially up at the top
part of the zone it has that spin we
talk about spin which it looks like it
has a little bit more carry a little
holds this line a little bit more where
hitters just aren't able to get on top
of that pitch and they'll tell you the
ball that comes in low looks like a ball
out of his hands that give up on it and
it catches the bottom part of the zone
but where he's effective is up in the
zone
maria's pops one up but it is going to
go out of play and maria is actually
home rudolph magee so he did get on top
of one
back in 2018 in august it was his fourth
major league game
there's a little history but a lot of
work to do for the brew crew offense
here in the nine
and it's why that swing in the back by
estrada is going to probably end up
playing pretty big here because this
brewer club is a club that doesn't give
up in a one-run game it's a lot
different feel than it is in a forehand
game going into the ninth inning
[Applause]
to center and comes oh dubon
that's great coverage
what a play by mauricio dubon welcome
back to the big league club
he's an athlete can play everywhere you
don't lose anything defensively he's
above average everywhere he plays you
can put him short he'll make great plays
we've seen him make these plays in
center when he's given the opportunity
all year long when he's been in the big
leagues
he can make up for lack of jump or route
with his athleticism and his speed great
play right there just impressive he was
my shortstop in the brewers minor
leagues and i've seen him make some
amazing plays never in center field
never in a big moment like that he's
just
such a fun guy to watch play very
exciting sick athlete
yes plays up the middle of the field
toughest two positions and can get it
done
at a high
i mean the closing speed for dubai
because i thought off the bat that it
was going to be a base hit because he
froze which you're supposed to do or
first step back but
he was able to close that ground in a
hurry
now it's yellidge
rare slider from jake mcgee don't mix
that in from time to time and we've seen
it a lot more as of late
just just more of a show me pitch
try to get you off the fastball
the youtube player of the game poll is
live
show the options again in a moment
there you go slater webb
rough
estrada it's going to be a tough one
today
that's going to be a tough call
ruff had the go-ahead knock yeah which
could be the difference
webb had the dominant pitching
performance slater had the homer to
start but estrada had the three-run
blast that kind of put him away or so
you would think
you have two pitchers in the booth right
here so yeah i bet mcgee's like let's
just go ahead and give that trophy to
the bond right there that was
good job by casalli to keep it close
enough
long stays put at first i was gonna say
it looked like he went he did
yeah you did christian yelich is a
strikeout victim
well rarely do you see jake mcgee strike
somebody out with a slider but
against the lefty yelich gets him to
chase yellows thinking the same thing
where's that 98
of the time fastball supposed to throw
me a fastball there
brewers won the first three in this
four-game set
never trailed
today flipped the script so far
and look who it is the birthday boy
willie adams last chance for milwaukee
this is the part of the order they
wanted up in the ninth got the lead off
spot at the top of the order
they put in willie adamus play shortstop
in the last inning there he is coming up
to bat in a big moment trying to keep
things alive the birds have done this a
lot a lot of comebacks
this would be quite the feed
willie doesn't know that tim dillard put
his helmet on before the game though and
took every ounce of luck
it was in there yeah out of it
this could be bad
hopefully no one will tell him
an adamus-like performance on the mic
from dilly today
[Applause]
runner's going
and that's down
no contest nope
defensive indifference
[Applause]
what does bob euchre say about that who
cares something like that
brandon bell's playing in right field i
don't think that
[Applause]
they're worried about colton wong
it's all on adamus
he was hitting in garcia's spot garcia
went over three with three strikeouts
today adamus goes to right we'll see if
that one's playable for slater backing
up and if it's fair it's gone it's gone
[Applause]
happy birthday william thomas
number 23 on the season two run shot
ends up in the bay
[Applause]
well there was a home run in that in
that helmet billy you could take some
credit for that one well before i take
credit let's just see what these guys
are
oh they're looking oh man
he knew it was foul foul ball billy
can't wait to take the credit for this
one
he cannot wait you know they're going to
look it over i mean we're in the ninth
originally called the homer switched
around after the
ump conference
craig council is heated
i mean we're gonna look at it
he just got 10 he's tossed
well he's heated because stu surewater
immediately calls it a home run and then
immediately calls all the umpires over
to see if he got it
right and then they didn't even review
it and they just overturned it
you figure they're going to review it
now
well if you don't they don't review it
gabe kepler was pouncing on the on the
headset so he wanted him to review it
right away and they will
council has been tossed so it was like
yes home run i'm sure wait let's chat
about it yeah he said fair turned around
and then went got all the empire i mean
sometimes in here at the moment you're
gonna make mistakes yeah but council's
point all year long is that when it
comes to the umpiring crew it feels like
they make
these weird calls at the
biggest moments in the game
oh you see just foul
[Applause]
yeah they got the call wrong and then
they got it right
frustrating for a manager
it's almost like the umpires will make a
call knowing that they have the security
blanket of replay
that tim dillard helmet magic
not there
yet
2-2 to adamus we'll see if he can do it
again
[Applause]
opposite field that one twisted well
foul
one more time
it didn't take long once it was under
review yeah that's
never never lose sight of the ball which
means that it was foul i think what they
were trying to determine hey i think stu
actually the first base umpire i think
he actually thought it might have
deflected off of it i think that was
kind of the was it inside the pole no
but right there is a tough
to see whether it hit off of it or just
wait near it
i didn't want to call it but
stu made me do it
this one's on the ground it's going to
be a tough play at second for estrada of
course he makes it game over hit a home
run make a great play to end the game
will that get you a trophy though it
might 5-1 we will find out so the giants
were out of first place for about 17
hours
they're back in there tied with the
dodgers heading into a weekend set
against la the giants improved to 85 and
49 on the year but the brewers take the
series they win three out of four
they dropped to 82 and 53 on the season
in a game that took two hours and 31
minutes to complete
the giants
pick up a w salvage a game in this
series
what a day
and it ended like this
kairos pumped it's a good day at the
ballpark for for tyrostrado donovan
solano wilmer flores on the il he gets a
chance to start has a huge hit great
defense
nice game and he's one of two
right-handed hitters to ever homer off
devin williams in the major leagues
let's talk about it post-game show time
or right now
it's the mlb game of the week live on
youtube post game show presented by
state farm 30 minutes with you
us scotbron sean estes tim dillard amyg
will join us shortly we'll get some
player interviews for you too 30 minutes
dedicated to the brewers and the giants
what a series this was awesome if you
watched all four these are competitive
ball clubs it had a playoff atmosphere
every single day some of the players
talked about that and today it went to
the giants and that's why gabe kapler
said forget about the dodger series i'm
going with logan webb today because we
need to wipe away this four game losing
skit it doesn't taste good
no i went to their stopper in in in
logan webb he won
the last 13 games he's getting up two
runs or less now make that 14 games the
giants have won 12 out of 13 out of the
last 14 games that he's pitched so uh
the right guy on the mound yes you need
to win the game today now you're tied
with the dodgers going into a big series
against them this weekend uh but uh yeah
great answer back after a tough three
games against the brewers for this giant
team and eric lauer on the mountain for
the brewers was outstanding this was the
best start all season long against a
really good team and let's be honest for
the brewers that try to go for the
supermarket sweep against the giants in
a four game that's tough to do that is
tough to do i think it came to a
culmination against devon williams in
that eighth inning i think it was just a
culmination the entire series of the
giants finally coming together with some
good at bats and getting some good
swings at some really good pitches
i like that is that a signature dilly
phrase supermarket sweep yeah as well
i really enjoy that show
that's the four gamer yeah yeah yeah
yeah for not your traditional three
games for about ten years i've called it
super sweep i like supermarket though
trademarked a little extra something
okay so giants take this one and if you
go back and if you missed anything we're
going to give you full highlights in
just a few we're going to chat with a
few players post game first and also
we'll give you the results of the poll
the youtube player of the game but it
was austin slater with the home run on
the first pitch for the giants offense
then they didn't score for a while i
mean we saw textbook brewers pitching
where they shut down the giants up until
the eighth inning and you thought san
francisco might be in trouble just due
to the fact that devin williams was down
yesterday so he was ready to go today
and just did not have his best stuff
this was
one of the defining moments technically
ruff had the winning hit but tyro
estrada with the extra padding that
really made a difference
yeah big swing in the back by estrada
cap or council had it set up the way he
wanted he had lauer pitched seven
innings longest start of his year
then he was going to go to the back end
of that bullpen to get it done and uh it
just
every once in a while that happens i
don't care how good you are how good a
pitch you do have sometimes you just get
beat hitters just beat you
it wasn't like there were mistakes he's
been doing it all year long giants just
got good wood on him today he was doing
it in this series too he pitched the
last game against the twins and then
came straight here pitched the first day
got up the second day
got hot did not come into the game so he
was off yesterday quick turnaround in
the day game so his stuff was still good
it just didn't wasn't enough to get it
done today you got two quick outs in
that inning giants did all their damage
with two outs logan webb had the good
stuff again he's going to join us now
logan webb joins us on the post game
show in general just a moment like 10
seconds on
come on high fiving he already iced his
arm yeah i didn't have to pitch the last
two innings where are you
only
seven strong today from logan webb he
was dealing this afternoon for san
francisco picked up a career high in
terms of the whips too that's the swing
and miss there he is logan webb joining
us right now logan congratulations on
the w for the team
and a big one in a series against a very
tough opponent in the milwaukee brewers
first let's run through what you did on
the mound today how do you evaluate your
performance and as i mentioned more wips
than we've ever seen from you in your
career uh yeah we just uh tried to
attack the guys they got a really good
team
um you know we
had a good game plan going in um you
know
just try to go out there and compete you
know i think we we really needed to win
as a team and
you know coming up late and doing all
that it was it was awesome hey logan
it's so good that you now get a little
extra hardware this year i know you're
going for some other hardware but here
it comes the youtube player of the game
trophy it's got a little weight to it
right yes it does bicep curls
thank congratulations that's all you
will have your name engraved in that one
for the performance today to a global
audience on youtube as we show off the
line seven innings ten strikeouts and
really this has been stretching now this
good stuff for a while so has anything
been different that you've noticed or
that you've worked on as part of your
game over the last couple months that's
taken you to another level
you know i think uh it's something cap
has said a bunch and it's something i've
talked to buster and kurt a lot about is
just attacking the zone
when you attack the zone good things
happen and
i feel like that's just been the main
thing over this i don't know past 14 15
starts
hey logan sean estes here
congratulations nice win today the club
needed it i got a couple questions did
you feel a little bit more pressure
taking the mountain today knowing that
your club really needed you you lost
four straight
you pitched so well as of late did you
feel any added pressure especially as
well as lauer was pitching today
not really pressure
i think the adrenaline was up a little
bit today it felt to me like warming up
and everything felt like a playoff type
game and
um
like i said this team's the the brewers
are unreal and got a really good staff
good lineup and
i was just super excited to pitch today
and
i think uh warming up and knowing we had
gone through a little you know rough
patch a little more adrenaline today
yeah i got a question for you too may
11th he pitched against the rangers he
had a rough first inning he kind of
labored through that inning kind of got
deliberate through a bunch of pitches i
believe 25.
i had heard that either casali or buster
maybe has said something in between
innings about you picking up your pace a
little bit
attacking the strike so i'm working a
little bit quicker is that what happened
because i feel like that since that
start is really when you've taken off
yeah that's been the
that was a big thing for me you know i i
talked to woody about it a bunch too you
know that guy's a little more
crazy than i am with the pace but i
think when i get my pace going um you
know i think that just gets me in into
that attack mode and when i do that you
know good things good things happen
logan webb tim dillard up here with
these guys listen i got a great question
for you it's not really a great question
you're a slider against lefties where
does that you as a right-handed pitcher
thrown against lefties you don't always
have that reference point for me that
was huge early on locating that slider
down and in on the lefties with so many
lefties in the lineup
can you talk to that a little bit is
that something that you work on all the
time is that something that you just
come out of the hat throwing it but i
feel like that right there was the
building block for later on getting guys
out with change up
yeah
i feel like in spring uh in the early
parts of the season it was i was real
change up heavy especially the lefties
and i think i think geyser started
sitting on that and you know it's
something that we worked on the bullpens
and
talking to buster and and kurt about it
kind of just
letting it play
kind of setting up outside letting it
play and just kind of throwing the crap
out of it and
um
kind of letting it do its thing and uh
it was huge today uh it's been a good
pitch that i've been
you know really working on and trying to
hone in on so um excited about how how
it how it went today logan we love the
slider the frisbee we love the pace keep
it up congrats on the w and we'll see
you down the line all right sounds good
see you guys thank you thank you youtube
player of the game logan webb hey
pitchers in the booth
you win today 51 of the pie logan webb
is your youtube player of the game for
his dominant performance for san
francisco he was the stopper of the
streak much more on the post game show
coming up
he
just smokes it
[Music]
great baseball right there
[Applause]
strike three
that was a great play
i talked about his fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
[Music]
and something like this is what they
came for
[Applause]
back in the booth it's the post game
show presented by state farm this was a
fun one it was tight the brewers and the
giants locked in one apiece for quite a
while and then the giants put up four
runs in the eighth inning one on an rbi
double for darren rupp we'll show you it
all in just a few and then a three run
shot for tyro estrada here's some math
for you ready for this dilly so the
giants put together four runs in that
eighth you go back to the previous how
many is it let's see
six runs in the previous 44 innings so
the offense had been a bit chilly a bit
cold and that's the turnaround that
they're looking for i mean that was the
culmination of the whole thing i mean
the game being you know so much tension
you could cut it with a knife and you
kind of want it to last but it was a
culmination of the giants coming out
finally some of those good at bats
paying off it just it's disappointing
that devon williams had to be on the
receiving end of that he's been such so
good for so long pitcher of the month in
august but that's kind of what it comes
down to it's hard to hold good teams at
bay for long we've seen the brewers do
it i know the giants are doing it and
they did it today you know what i was
laughing at logan webb said playoff feel
and we've heard that from a few players
this week i'm going you haven't pitched
in the playoffs yet
well if you did this is what it would
feel like yeah yeah maybe a little bit
more more more at stake in the playoffs
but uh speaking of the playoffs this
team inevitably will be a playoff team
now where they are they going to play a
one game playing game with a winner take
all or are they going to have to play
are they gonna get to play five games um
the way the dodgers are playing right
now it's gonna be tough to win this
division and so now you look ahead as
like try to get as healthy as you can
and who's gonna pitch that one game and
he's making a case right now to be that
guy might even be a little piggyback
action with the gossman and logan webb
if it ends up being a wild card but
they'd love to just win the division
they have the same record as the dodgers
they were a half game back heading into
today but the giants win and here's how
it happened
we begin with austin slater last night
over three with a walk in this time
first pitch going after it deep center
field and
forget about it
austin slater muscles up and the giants
are on the board with one pitch it's
their first lead of the series making
one nothing on his tenth of the season
bradley strikes out it's been a tough
season for him at the plate and webb has
k number three
[Music]
that's a pretty good one
shawn will answer later because logan
webb is oh so economical this afternoon
now nine up nine down
and wong is down on strikes logan webb's
fifth punch out already this afternoon
amy g logan webb is looking good
[Music]
maria's into the corner and that is
going to punch off the wall
and turn into a stand-up double
[Applause]
a one out double for ureas
marias and yellows are on for garcia
2-2 on its way
got him
six strikeouts already for logan webb
on to jace peterson clutch city last
night as well two out two strike rbi
single made it 3-2 that was the go ahead
run
lofts one into shallow center it's going
to drop and aureus is on his way home
the throw is going to catch
in between second and third but the
brewers do get a run yell it's still on
the run
crawford is going to make the tag for
the out
to end the inning but the brewers get
their first run of the day
jase peterson a little bloop rbi knock
and scores orious one per side now if
logan webb is shaking his head and
saying a few things that might not be
safe for youtube
the pitcher on the way swinging the miss
he's struck him out with a change up
[Applause]
second time that he's
punched out jackie bradley jr seven
strikeouts now in four and two third
innings recorded by
logan webb
haley clocks one to left field and he
finds some open space
he's gonna truck to second luke maley
sends a ball all the way to the left
field corner it's a two out double here
in the pit
[Music]
[Applause]
freezing for frozen making
eight strikeouts this afternoon for mr
webb trying to wipe away this losing
skid for the giants
on to the seventh we go and daniel vogel
back
into the corner
good piece of that one but
do not test that arm of austin slater do
not test that arm of austin slater uh oh
daley he did it
he went for it i mean he put his head
down and ran i think he kind of cooled
off the jets around halfway to second
base but in that moment right there he's
trying to make something happen but
sometimes it's better to play it safe
i know it's been a slump over the past
couple weeks for the giants defense but
mostly on the season they've been great
and here's tyler rogers out of the
bullpen striking out the side
yeah you talked about not really a
strikeout guy and he hasn't been all
year long he can get you a strikeout
every once in a while but he's more of a
pitch to contact ground ball guy but had
an unbelievable
three strikeout inning performance today
and devin williams is rare did not have
it
chris bryant is going to come on down on
the darren rough double
to grab the lead for san francisco and
then eventually tyro estrada see ya
that's for three
and that allowed giant fans to exhale a
little bit more because now they had a
four run lead going into the ninth
inning instead of just the one run lead
and in that nine mauricio dubon was just
called up today when flores to the
injured list and dubai says look at me i
can fly
took a little uh
interesting route to the ball of more of
a banana route but he was in the end he
was able to
close the
the gap with his athleticism we thought
williams had a home run that was the
call it was overturned
then the outback continues and he
bounces out to
who else but tyro estrada and the giants
pick up the w what a game today for us
on youtube giants five brewers one both
teams are just awesome though these are
three of the top teams in the national
league it's brewers giants and dodgers
getting it done all season long we've
got more for you on the post game show
presented by state farm another
interview coming your way with amy g
checking in in just a moment
there's the basic
wong slaps one to left here comes kane
aquino's throw to the plate and kate is
in there
rbi single
colton wong
it is 4-2 cincinnati
oh
wrong sends it deep to right and she's
gone
colton long
two-run home run
and on runs for the brewers in the
bottom of the eighth it is 7-4 now my
goodness how big is that
he's come up with some huge hits
and big home runs
two-out
two-run home run
colton wong with three rbis in his last
two at-bats long now top of the order he
has struck out twice in this one and
this one line down the left right field
line
and it's gonna play to run for milwaukee
two runs come home
took a while for the brewers bats to get
going in this series but here they are
that was a change up first pitch
and colton able to wait back that pitch
was up down the middle and smokes it
down the right field line
life-size to connect for it's all going
down on the field at oracle park after
this one but it was a show during the
game giants five brewers won that's your
final score darren ruff actually had the
game-winning shot it was double to make
it
2-1 and they end up tacking on three
more thanks to tyro estrada so we heard
from logan webb let's hear what daryn
ruff had to say with amy g
i have one of the heroes from today's
game and that's the offense darren that
giants fans have come to know and love
this season i we have a lot to break
down let's just start with the eighth
inning because you were responsible for
the go ahead run two outs an rbi double
from you and the brewers pitching staff
is so stellar how are you able to get to
devon williams take us through that a b
yeah you know um you know obviously uh
chris and and brandon working great at
bass before me um
and then just you know knowing his best
pitches just changed up he'd probably go
to it and you know luckily i was able to
keep it fair down the line
um and uh yeah i mean that you just in
that situation try to try to look for
the what
you know that the pitcher is going to go
to in that situation and
um yeah like i said was able to stay
inside of it keep it fair and and credit
to brandon and and chris before me and
uh and then tyro having a great at-bat
because you know those insurance runs
are always huge
it hasn't been very often this season
that the offense has cooled off and it
has the last few games but when you have
endings like that and you know pitching
so contagious do you feel like you get
back on track a little bit yeah
hopefully i mean uh
we luckily have not really struggled as
much as we have uh this this little
stretch all year so
hopefully we can get back on track we'll
have an awesome series this weekend and
[Music]
and yeah it'll it'll be fun to to get
the offense rolling again big series
coming in but let's talk about logan
webb and i'm so glad i'm doing the
interview with you because you have a
lot of perspective in this game you've
been around long enough to know the ebbs
and the flows and logan's kind of just
learning that but everyone has commented
on his maturation in this game and his
confidence in this game and he had a lot
of pressure on him today to be the
stopper and stop this skid that you guys
were in just your thoughts on on where
he's at in his career how impressive he
was today how impressive he's been this
season
yeah i mean i don't know if i have the
right words to to say you know how how
important
logan has been over the last couple
months to this team and even earlier but
i just remember going back to spring
training how how everyone was commenting
on how great he looked
and i feel like early on in the season
he might have been putting a little too
much pressure on himself to go out there
and then you know dealt with some arm
issues um got himself right and boy has
he been
amazing for us over the last couple
months um
is i just seeing
you know getting able to watch some of
the games on tv if i if i'm not starting
that uh the movement on his pitches his
two-seam is his change up in his slider
are you know three three really really
good pitches so he has stepped up big
time all right last question for you um
you can't make it any more dramatic
darren it doesn't happen so you guys
were out of first place place for about
17 hours dodgers come in and you are
tied for first place against your nl
west foes kepler said something
interesting today he said there's a
sense of urgency but there's no need to
panic and you guys have done a really
good job of that but we're in september
and the number of games you have left
are you know they're limiting each time
you play a game so how do you do that
how do you navigate between urgency and
panic
um
well
knowing that yeah these three games are
important but
um knowing like you said we have i don't
know 20 some left after that too as well
but obviously we want to play play
really well uh be really really
competitive uh make the plays we're
supposed to have great at bats um just
just play solid baseball and uh i think
if if we play solid baseball play
fundamentally sound
have quality at bats
we're we're an amazing team and that
that's all you can ask no matter who
you're playing so you make it sound
really easy oh it's not easy i know it's
not easy
i know i know darren ref congratulations
on today's win and thanks for your time
we appreciate it thank you amy g and
darren ref sports gaming universe said
it not me not often williams gets
roughed up like that
how do you do
your thoughts oh on the pun yeah that's
a great pun it's good yeah it just it's
unfortunate because you start looking at
uh you know how that came about but
that's what it came down to was going
okay i'm going to look for a pitch and i
thought it was a great comment he was
just surprised he was able to keep it
fair like that was really the difference
maker in this game that led to
everything else and we also were
entertained by rowdy telez all day long
rowdy take it away
hey does anybody want to be friends with
me today
anybody
anybody want to be friends with me today
just because i don't want to come out
yeah hey just because i got a microphone
i mean we can't be friends get your hugs
a little baby
[Applause]
fail one two one two check check
i think brandon crawford is one of the
best league games in baseball
[Music]
his connect the city connect jerseys
sick paint job on the cleats had like
the golden gate bridge like it was
pretty sick yeah
and this one's last night we're made by
nike because like all-star games and
stuff you get a certain amount also you
can just nike makes them for you
but we win a couple world series some go
a bunch of old gloves world you know
see i told you check out his cleats dude
[Music]
he's got a good he's got a good clean
i told him that i'm first yesterday i
said dude
i mean that's you don't have to be
humble or nothing but like
yeah you gotta have a top five complete
game in the game right he was like i
like think so
did his city connect ones
were painted on and he said i think it's
souls by sir
that's free marketing but
they're sold by sir did you get that on
the mic uh
his those are sick
sick
okay
one world series ring two homers
you coming out in the fourth
third i lied thirty once you put that
time man
okay
how the hell you get miked up out of all
people they said because what the hell
you what you got a half a year in the
show and you mic'd up three three let's
see let's get this right sorry let's get
this right been there done that yeah
well dude this isn't 1937 anymore when
you debut all right
relax
i don't know man we just got a
microphone just let them know there's a
bunch of people up there though let them
know casey got my good yields
i don't know i've seen you lean on some
stuff man i saw some good years it's
coming out but milwaukee showed that
love yeah but hey let them know
i got a mic today hey lolo watch out uh
i already told him willie gets miked and
doesn't tell nobody and tries to sneak
to sneak attack some stuff
shut up willy they put that theme there
willie shut up
dude i liked you when you were young
i liked you when you were young were the
tigers i liked it
it's my birthday it's really his
birthday what's the camera i don't know
what camera we're looking at but we'll
be over there everybody out there hey
it's my birthday today this is his
birthday so
thank you please compliant
oh what a sweet ending and they finally
found the camera after all that
at the buzzer consecutive starts
allowing two runs or less
logan webb you're almost there
this guy did it in 1916 and 17. i wasn't
calling these games i debuted a few
years later longest by giant since 1900
13-1 during that streak
ferdi shoop
is the name
i i can't say i've ever heard of them
but it's a great name it's a really good
name
i'm just hearing that too bad already
got three kids you know they've been a
great name to play that's a classic yeah
he was born in 1891
played
1916-17 had to be in new york new york
giants
so san francisco giant era logan webb
now has the record for most consecutive
two games with two runs or less and then
you saw the guy right behind him
uh was kevin gausman he did it this year
that shows you how impressive those two
guys have been at different times this
year and logan's not finished
and it helps to have a guy too that is
along for the ride with you look at the
brewers staff if you look at those three
top pitchers in woodruff burns and
peralta and they're kind of going
through the story together
and you need that you need that from
pitchers that have been there johnny
cueto's been there and so he's an
integral part of what the giant's got
going on but it's always good to have
somebody alongside you for that ride
peralta is back tomorrow he's starting
for milwaukee coming off the injured
list he had a little shoulder issue and
a little bit of news post game that we
heard from craig council he said that
abaceo garcia was removed from this game
precautionary but some back and
hamstring tightness so it's that time of
year where milwaukee is somewhat in
cruise control dilly so you want to make
sure that you are at full strength come
october because they're sitting pretty
in the division they are and they have
this room to kind of be
patient with guys and make sure they're
completely healthy before they start
running them back out there for that
final deep plunge going into the
playoffs so smart move there he's played
almost in more games than anyone else
for the milwaukee brewers so to get him
some rest that's a good thing
we actually are going to go on the field
after this and play some games i mean
there's table jenga there's life-size
connect four that looks like a good time
sean did they do this after all the
games i'll take in bags cornhole
cornhole for sure it's that and then of
course the seagulls taking over right
now at oracle park but truly this was a
fun one i also just want to give a
special shout out to our producer
michael traynor and his wife alexis they
welcomed a baby girl born august 22nd
aubry addison trainer welcome to the
world aubrey we actually share a
birthday august 22nd you're a leo you
might not comprehend or know that yet
but you will eventually mike we will see
you back on the road next week we miss
you buddy this was an absolute blast
thank you guys we appreciate everyone
watching worldwide on youtube and we do
this every week on youtube globally this
one is a final
the brewers fall to the giants they do
take the series though and the mlb game
of the week live on youtube is going to
swing back on wednesday september 8th
two more playoff hopefuls we have the
first place astros in the al west
hosting a pesky division rival the
seattle mariners our pregame show will
start rolling at 1 30 eastern next week
for the greats today tim dillard sean
estes amy g our entire superstar crew
out west i'm scott braun logging out for
now
great one today see you next time on
youtube
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you